San Francisco is all kind of messed up
you got
human waste all over the streets you got
crime rampant through the streets as
well there's this viral video where 10
people just run out of a building just
stealing stuff and people are are heard
saying I guess crime is legal and we've
been hearing this for a while now the
funny thing is you've got this
Progressive district attorney
so now that this this study comes out
showing 40 percent of people in San
Francisco I think registered voters have
said they're planning on leaving or
considering leaving because of the lower
quality of life and the crime and
there's this big threat talking about it
this Progressive D.A who's supposed to
be arresting and Prosecuting these
people said well that's just because uh
they're racist that their their fears
are just linked to racism it's like the
easiest way to not take responsibility
for screwing up your city so I want to
talk about this in a bunch of other
social issues around you know what's
happening with crime in New York City
how it's uh how it's come to this but
we're gonna be spending a lot of time
talking about dating and uh economic
attractiveness we have this article
where it's it's basically a collection
of tick tocks of from women who posted
photos of themselves before they met
their boyfriends or husbands and they're
all slim and attractive and they're like
here's me now and they're like uncamped
in obese and that this plays into a lot
of dating tropes and we got some guys
who I guess are experts maybe are you
guys experts in a fresh podcast somewhat
I know I would hope so yeah he was
following every now and then you know
every now and then we try to womanize
maybe I don't know just just random
dudes or something I got a bunch of
people following you
[Laughter]
so we'll talk a lot about this this is
important too because
the feminism dating how the media plays
it how the dating apps play it has a
huge impact on our political space you
know politics is Downstream from culture
so a lot of the things that we see
really are rooted in
I guess a lot of it's feminism but a lot
of its intersectionality or critical
race Theory and all this stuff so so
we're gonna know that you guys want to
just actually do an intro for yourselves
yeah sure sure so we're fresh and fit
man I mean you've seen us all over Tick
Tock Worldstar you know the fights all
that stuff but Behind These scenes man
we're just some guys from Miami living
life I mean it's not a whole women think
how men think put them all in one room
together we made sense of the whole
arguments that they have so pretty much
yeah man uh basically our podcast we
help men become better you know through
Fitness finances and you know dealing
with girls you know because obviously
dating is tough for a lot of guys out
here yeah so uh you know we talk about a
lot of uncomfortable truths in the
dating game and teach guys what it
really takes to be attractive despite
you know how unflattering or Politically
Incorrect it is did you guys say your
names yet oh yeah well Aaron Martin
Gaines CEO yeah Martin Gaines man AKA uh
fit and then he's fresh a freshman CEO
yeah AKA Walt Walter Weeks yeah yeah
hello everyone Ian croslin over here
glad you guys are here I think a lot
about how was it politics is Downstream
of culture I think that culture is
Downstream of Technology depending on
how you twist and bend technology you're
going to massively different culture we
see this with Bumble and online dating a
lot of that has contributed to this yeah
that's that's yeah online dating this
this mobile technology changed a lot of
how we we have dating culture yeah
social media itself man has changed the
whole landscape because now access is
abundant so yeah yeah we got a lot of
talk about this but we're gonna we're
gonna work our way into that too through
just you know regular old politics but
uh we got a lady push a button I'm also
in the corner I'm really excited about
this because I was talking to these guys
before the podcast and uh we agree on a
lot more than most people probably
realize so I'm stoked for this pretty
base conversation earlier yeah it was
getting really spicy before we even
started Ryan's going to be fun it's
gonna be fun but we're gonna we're gonna
ease into it we're just gonna go over
some of these some of these new stories
up front and then uh we're gonna get
into yeah yeah but don't forget before
we start go to timcast.com become a
member and you'll get asked access to
exclusive members only content we've got
awesome segments one of them from Dr
Chris Martinson actually I can't I can't
even show you on the website on the
screen because the title of it would get
us banned off YouTube that's that's kind
of stuff that we're talking about and
this guy's a PhD pathologist talking
about you know what's going on with
covet so we have to have these
conversations off uh off of YouTube and
on the site but you're also helping
support our Newsroom we are we are we
just uh uh we got two more journalists
coming on who are going to be doing a
lot of news and stuff we are going to be
working on launching the The Unexplained
Mysteries podcast this weekend because
we never stopped working we'll be
filming the Vlog all that's at
timcast.com so so please become a member
plus we're gonna have a bonus segment
coming up later tonight after the show
ends we record one just for members
where we're allowed to say all the
things that YouTube would ban us for and
that will be probably pretty fun because
even before the show these guys I think
it's going to be a blast but uh don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends if you really do like it's the
most powerful thing you can do we don't
get the marketing budget of CNN anything
or anything like that but if you're like
hey man this is a really great show just
share it on Facebook share it on Twitter
do whatever because people are saying
they're not getting the notifications
they're not getting you know shown the
podcast some people are saying they go
to the channel it's not even there that
happens yup yup but we're also on iTunes
Spotify so we're trying to spread
everything around and get people to go
to uh
you know um our website timcast.com but
you can follow the show at Tim cast IRL
on Instagram and Facebook let's talk
about this uh this first story real
quick and uh let's let's see what's
going on we got the story from Fox News
San Francisco D.A official says I'm
sorry I I keep I actually I keep
screwing this up I said this was Chessa
Bowden it's not the D.A oh it's the D.A
official who says crime surge fears
linked to racism it's similar
considering the district attorney is
supposed to be the one that's
Prosecuting all this crime reports of
vehicle break-ins are up by between 100
and 750 in parts of San Francisco and
we're seeing stuff like this all over we
got this story from the Daily Mail
crime is basically legal in San
Francisco Furious Shopper post video of
horde of shoplifters fleeing Neiman
Marcus totally unchecked with armfuls of
designer bags so uh we'll just we'll
just we'll just jump in I mean I've been
talking about this stuff for a while I
don't want I lived in the Philadelphia
area I don't want to live there because
there were riots there was a it's not
even about the riots there was one story
where a guy barricaded himself inside a
building and started shooting at cops
like I think he shot like five people
and so at a certain point I'm just like
why am I even living in a place like
this yeah but especially over the past
year with crime skyrocketing everywhere
you guys are in Miami I'm wondering what
you guys have noticed about uh yeah
breaking into cars sounds like Winwood
yeah literally like you go down to party
with your friends whatever in a cool
spot area yeah come on their cars it's
open Wynwood is uh it's it's basically
like think of it as like our
Williamsburg of like uh New York or
Brooklyn it's like you know going
through gentrification very similar to
Austin a lot of graffiti a lot of artsy
sorry yeah it's like right there in that
Art District area so you know but it's
going that used to be the hood back in
the day so now what's going on is like a
lot of car break-ins a lot of people
getting robbed and everything like that
and and Philly is like always
consistently in the top five or ten most
dangerous cities in the US man so yeah I
guess like this like the recurring theme
with all of this is that these cities
are typically run by democrats yes yes
yes yes I don't know how political you
guys get because you talk a lot about
data Miami is uh we were the last County
to open after the beer bug stuff you
know what I'm saying uh yeah we're the
last County because Florida was open for
a while but Miami-Dade was the slowest
we just opened back up maybe what a
month ago a month ago so yeah we're
pretty they're pretty that's one of the
craziest things is you have that you
have that county that was like safe
Democrat that flipped Republican was
that yeah that was Miami wasn't it was
that north of Miami is it Miami-Dade it
might have been Broward Broward is that
one area that's like it's like I think
it might have been Broward yeah right
yeah because Miami Dade is typically
always blue but uh I wouldn't be
surprised if Broward like went red for a
bit because Broward is like a lot more
diverse yeah than South Florida well it
is South Florida but it's much more
diverse in Miami-Dade yeah it was Miami
there you go okay I was right
I don't know which uh 27th
27th district and 27th 26th that was
crazy because they uh they were saying
that it was safe Democrat it wasn't
going to change but there's like I guess
the main theme of the story that we're
going on is when you look at I think San
Diego was run by Republicans they're not
in the top ten for Crime even though in
the top 10 biggest cities so I don't I
don't know if what's your guys's opinion
on this San Diego is great man I like
San Diego I'm not a fan of California
but San Diego I do like so nice just in
general for like the crime we're seeing
honestly what's it like in Miami
um for Crime it's kind of like how to
put this it's more in the party scene I
would say this like let's say you're
going out friends right you meet a girl
guys are getting like finesse from girls
like for example you bring to your house
you know you have a great time but then
you wake up your stuff is gone
and then
regular civilian walking around whatever
uh certain areas obviously still not
safe but I would say Morris like car
break-ins you know guys getting finesse
from girls and then also you know even
behind the scenes there's like um you
know death with scammers you know people
does it feel like it's going up
um I'll say this um Miami Beach has
definitely changed significantly over
the past you know 10 15 years you know
ever since for me what I noticed the
trigger point was right around 2008 when
Florida started getting on the map with
DJ Khaled and Lil Wayne and all these
rappers like really like representing
this South Florida area and then it
brought more tourism more traffic to
Miami because a lot of people think
Miami Beach like oh Ocean Drive they
think that's Miami no that's Miami Beach
yeah but Miami Beach now it's it could
be ratchet at times like Memorial Day
weekend you don't want to be there so um
but yeah there there's a lot of crime in
Miami Beach because you know it draws a
certain crowd there on certain types of
events and then yeah a lot of fights
shootings robberies you know in Miami
Beach quite a bit I would say the main
area Miami Beach because we're in
Brickell don't tell us we're kind of
like in a safe area so to speak but like
crazy like you know and then downtown
Miami has like all the homeless people
yeah like all the homeless people in my
area downtown yeah dude yo okay get this
right so I came here five years ago to
Miami right from Barbados and downtown
brick was kind of like okay open area
not too much people over there not too
many homeless now it's like overrun but
you know the pandemic all this stuff
happens people are out of jobs that's
where they go Brickell is like the
Manhattan of Miami if I was to give
people like an example of what it is
it's like the financial district it's
clean it's nice like you know they've
been really working on making it nice
because it used to be when people came
to Miami they would go to Miami Beach
immediately they would never go into the
city right like you actually would never
go into the city unless you worked but
now you know the city is becoming more
tourist friendly they're trying to
compete with Miami Beach that's why
Winwood is coming up the Design District
Brickell has its own uh its own scene
and everything else like that but so
it's like it's fixing but yeah I mean
there's definitely like a lot of
scammers in Miami a lot of girls Rob
dudes people don't know it's just that
the guys don't report it to the computer
report it you know what I'm saying I
lived in Miami for a little bit uh I was
in by Homestead actually where where
that famous child attention migrant
facility or whatever and we had uh one
crazy thing happened the neighbors
warned us that there were some home
invasions and people were shot and
killed and so I think this is why why
this is what explains a lot of like you
know Florida gets a republican Governor
Ron DeSantis everybody loves the guy you
know and they're saying he might run for
president or maybe he'll be vice
president who knows but when I was there
this is a story I often tell people I
was at a trump rally talking to people
about this because uh you know this was
this is back in the day or it was like
six years ago there was there were some
home invasions a guy was in a shower
and he heard noise downstairs like
rustling so he walks downstairs in his
towel and then two guys see him and then
just one guy just shoots him in the
chest kills him and this is this is like
40 miles west of Miami so it's like not
that far away okay and you know so I was
talking to people in the neighborhood
about there like you got to be really
careful you know you I hope you have
guns and we're alive we didn't have any
guns we're in the middle of nowhere but
we weren't armed or anything like that
we had like an air pressure rifle and so
then talking to talking to these people
a lot of them were Latino immigrants a
lot of them were Cuban yeah and they
said oh yeah those like we're talking
our neighbors about it and they're like
oh yeah those guys oh yeah they killed
it I think they caught them they were
illegal immigrants who like were
ransacking houses west of Miami where
it's like there's no cops it's Pitch
Black it's like farm houses oh probably
unincorporated Dade
Homestead is no man's land and there's
nothing out there it's very cheap over
there too so I get it yeah there's an
Air Force Base but that's about it yeah
but that that to me was one not like
when the people I see the Trump Flags
everywhere and I was talking at rallies
uh talking to people at rallies I was
like oh now I get it like this these are
the stories that they're hearing all the
time that's why they're very concerned
about illegal immigration that's why
they're very concerned about the guns
and things like that but uh anyway I
digress I you know I want to ask you
guys like how do you how do you manage
to do a podcast underwater you know
I heard Miami score sinking yeah we're
sinking every day bro we had a building
that just collapsed that's true Surfside
South Beach it might be terrible man why
was that they were figuring out why so
apparently the building had a very bad
structure it was had some issues going
on but they didn't they never fixed it
so they were told ahead of time hey guys
this building is under some you know
some you know issues you need to fix it
as soon as possible but then they never
did it and then what happened was I
think we had like a lot of rain a lot of
like um what what was it was like a
fissure or something like that yeah I
mean the thing about Miami is like a lot
of the buildings were built you know on
the back of you know the cocaine era you
know so it's like they're they're not
necessarily like Miami was built on the
back of like Narco trafficking so let's
be honest about it so like you know they
like and it's because I'm a real estate
investor in Miami too yeah it's not
uncommon for them to be breaking all
kinds of codes and violations when
you're like looking at real estate
property in Miami so I would not be
surprised if that building was uh didn't
pass certain regulations and it might
have like you know collapse on itself
yeah so somebody just greased some Palms
yeah you put some money over there yeah
you know like hey I gotta dump this
money in somewhere bro like somewhere so
real estate but imagine you're in your
home all of a sudden oh yeah that's
crazy yeah yeah and there's so many
buildings in mind like that so who knows
mommy might be underwater who really
knows one of your podcasts you know what
if like you're building your own dude
yeah it's important who knows because
I'll tell you this we're high up when it
rains
when Brickell uh when when it rains
really bad in Brickell like it does go
underwater like there's flood there's
like cuddles everywhere cars like are
driving through we're like it's like a
imagine you're at a lake and it's the
city it's that crazy so it's bad is it
really sinking though
or is it like because when I was there I
remember I went down to Miami Beach one
day and there was like a couple inches
of water just in the street and they
said oh it's because Miami's sinking but
other people told me it's been like this
forever it's like it's sea level so it
rains and then like there's nowhere to
drain the water so it just like is in
the streets so I'm wondering how much of
it's political because here's the thing
that they're saying that you know the
water levels are gonna rise climate
change and all that but you still got
all these investors buying a property
all across Miami yeah that's my question
dude why these millionaires dumping
money into a property that may go
underwater so I'm thinking they must be
doing something behind the scenes to
stop the you know not only that like me
and fresh are both involved in real
estate too and uh the market in Miami
right now is hot man like these these uh
if you guys are trying to buy a Miami
man this is going to be expensive
because these New York investors they're
moving down in yeah
people from Massachusetts New York
Connecticut the northeastern General are
moving down there in droves because
they're looking at like okay what did
the beer bug teach us okay well now you
can work from home you don't necessarily
need to be tied to a certain location to
be able to do work and commute in so why
are you going to pay three four five six
thousand dollars to live in a closet in
New York City when you can go down to
Florida warm all year no state income
tax and for a lot of people that don't
know this Florida is actually fairly
cheap to live and Miami is actually a
cheap city to live in you can get a
one-bedroom apartment in Brickell which
is in Manhattan Miami for uh two
thousand a month or less yeah you would
never find that in Manhattan nope my
friend had a had a place in Brickell
over overlooking like the bay and they
had two they had two pools for residents
a saltwater pool and a freshwater pool
yeah not that expensive it's like super
nice place people think Miami's
expensive but here's the thing it's
expensive if you party Miami since so
many people come to party in Miami Beach
it's expensive but if you actually live
in the city of Miami not that bad and if
you want to avoid sea level you can go
to Wynwood and that's above sea level it
is investors that's where they go to
invest and buy property that's going to
blow up soon yeah sorry go ahead no I
was gonna say man I think a lot of
people are moving down there because of
Freedom facts yeah I mean you had taxes
in Florida saying you know Mass you can
do whatever you want like life is normal
here yeah that's why people I think I
think a lot of people move to Florida so
our friend Luke for instance you know he
was on the show lukakowski for for a
couple months and then he's like I'm
leaving I'm going to Florida and he was
like you should come with and I'm like
bro we can't just go to Florida we went
to Florida I don't know what he's doing
now it's a great state man you should
come in I lived in Florida the problem
is you can't go outside
what the humidity
humidity it's like it's a hundred
degrees with the maximum humidity and
it's monsooning half the time I lived in
when I lived out there I'll be honest
bro I mean we stay inside most of the
time yeah I mean so you
I'll take warm weather because I grew up
in Connecticut so I grew up in the
Northeast I went to college in Boston
I'm very familiar with New England and
Northeastern General I lived in New York
City I've lived in Philly and it's just
like man I'll take that hot weather over
cold weather any day man like but that's
just me some people like the season
changing but like for me it's like it's
cheaper it's warmer the girls are hotter
you know listen I will say this though
here's my prediction Nevada Florida and
Texas are going to see huge migration of
new and why is that because uh they all
don't have state income tax and they're
all a lot of people are escaping major
cities that are expensive Las Vegas for
LA
a lot of people from New York have come
down to Florida Florida and then um
Texas everyone's just going to Texas
because Texas is a fantastic place if I
wasn't in Florida I'd be in Texas
Houston you could buy a beautiful home
for three hundred thousand dollars uh
you know it's it's uh Texas is a very
self-sufficient State gas is cheap food
is cheap they make a lot of their own
stuff very self-sufficient to say hell
if they wanted to leave the United
States they could don't they have that
on paper somewhere I think they do yeah
yeah so um the only thing that sucks is
like you know Houston traffic is awful
and you need a car but Texas is a great
place to be so I think those three
states in the next five to ten years you
guys are going to see an explosion
because now people are seeing I don't
have to be domain dependent on where I
am to like work I can work remotely so
if you're going to work remotely why not
pay less taxes and be in a warmer better
area there are there are some rumors I
haven't looked into this at West
Virginia is also trying to get rid of
their their well West Virginia is trying
to get rid of their income tax at least
a certain level I don't know if they're
actually going to do it or not I haven't
looked into it but a lot of people in
West Virginia are talking about it so I
like it out here man you know uh it's
close enough to the east coast couple
hours to Philly a couple hours to you
know you well not a couple hours but you
can head down to Miami enough to
difficult DC is right there yeah and uh
you're allowed to have guns because you
know you can you got a big big open
spaces and I like snowboarding you know
periodically maybe once or twice and I
want to go crazy with it but uh winter
is nice yeah New Hampshire I would say
New Hampshire is also uh good as well
for people that want to stay in New
England and still be able to get that
experience because there's no stating of
attacks in New Hampshire either and
you're just hop skipping away from uh
Massachusetts you know if you want to go
to Boston or Springfield or anything
like regarding like coastal cities
getting going underwater I think what
happens when that does happen is it
happens in jolts because if the if the
ice caps melt there will be like a rise
in in water but what happens is when the
ice is removed from the earth the earth
Rises where that ice used to be and
Earth Elsewhere on the planet goes down
so like it will literally sink so not
only does the water level rise but the
Earth sinks wait wait wait wait you're
saying the water would ice caps melt and
just disappear all in the day if there's
like a firestorm and all the ice caps
are gone all that land Rises where the
ice used to be compressing it goes up
and so Earth on other parts of the
planet go down when that when that land
goes up so the ice caps are removed part
of Earth will sink oh hold on bro and
that's in addition to the water rushing
well a lot of times climate change
happens in jolts it doesn't happen the
northern ice caps aren't on land you've
got Greenland which is on land and
doctor is Antarctica is I I depends on
depending on your Source Antarctica is
gaining ice in some areas maybe losing
Isis but if it were to lose its ice that
that that's you would see land sink as
well as water go up so I like those are
like the tectonic plates floating on
water you're saying it depends on what
theory you look at if you look at the
expanding Earth theory there are no
tectonics I don't think expanding Earth
theory is real I think we should go deep
on Extreme
I don't know man we're talking about
investing in real estate and everything
yeah well Lance seeking I don't think
it's going to sink I don't I think
buying it as a short-term
considered high risk investment when
it's not but I I just think it's weird
that I watched this video where a guy
made a really good point he's like all
these people are coming out claiming
that you know climate change is going to
wipe everything else the water level is
going to rise 20 feet and they're and
all these rich people are buying up
beachfront property in Miami like what
look either they're expecting it not to
happen or they're lying see that's the
question here why are they buying these
million dollar homes right on the water
something's something's up here they
know something something that we don't
know they have to maybe they're
Atlantean they can breathe underwater
yeah that's probably it yeah but I'm
seeing now in Miami they're putting like
these pillars in the water I don't know
what they do but it's supposed to like
stabilize the the I don't know what it
is but they're putting pillars in water
I don't know like wave breaks are they
Breaking the Waves is uh I don't know
what it does bro
what I think honestly is that yeah these
New Yorkers these New York investors
have so much money that like even if the
place was to flood or whatever it is
they can fix the damages like they can
they're buying it at such a low cost
that even buying it at that cost and
fixing the dam which is going to be
cheaper than buying a piece of property
in New York like I grew up in Brooklyn
New York right like uh and I uh in in
the right off Church Avenue right as a
kid like from zero to nine years old
then I moved that property I went and
like looked at it it's worth like two
million dollars now and it's like just
like a little crappy apartment like
building and it's like worth two million
dollars now so it's like New York uh
real estate you can't even get in the
game unless you have millions so it's
like oh I can go to Florida and buy like
a Triplex or a quad Plex or whatever or
maybe even an apartment building for
under a million yeah I'm gonna do that
but as an investor well on some of these
firms are probably just getting fed
money for free it's just they just get
loans from the banks they don't care
about what's what's the worst case
scenario if you buy this property and
30s is underwater whatever bankruptcy
you walk away why do they care is it is
it Blackstone that's doing that yeah
Black Rock and Blackstone right yeah
black black stone I think bought up a
company that that does this that buys
properties and rents them out and then I
think BlackRock was the one that was
buying up all the properties themselves
um I don't know there's like two
different companies I know right it's
annoying I'm just
I'm an investor it's my investor I don't
put money into someone that might lose
money so I'm just thinking from my point
of view hey I'm invest whether it's not
sea level problems I don't know yeah but
I'm just what I've come to realize is
like these New York investors they're
not even getting good cash on cash
returns like that they're barely
breaking 10 and they're still doing the
deal so that tells me that they just
have a bunch of money they need to get
rid of or something Have you have you
guys been tracking what's going on with
the the economy since like with covet
and stuff yeah it's a degree because
you're mentioning like you're a real
estate investor because we have another
story I want to talk about too we'll
jump into this and then we'll get into
the dating stuff after this one sure
supermarkets are now this is from The
Wall Street Journal supermarkets are
stockpiling inventory as food costs rise
Grocers are setting aside larger amounts
of frozen meat sugar and other items to
protect profits ahead of anticipated
price increases a lot of people think
that there's going to be like some kind
of Market collapse inflation's already
through the roof like like I mean the
Bacon's up like 20 gas is up you know
highest and it's been in seven years now
grocery stores are trying to buy as much
as they can right now yeah what was it
like six bucks in L.A yeah we were just
in L.A we were out to Adam 22 no jumper
we were over there and we were in La for
a couple for a couple days and the gas
was outrageous like six bucks seven yeah
six months yeah six bucks I'm not gonna
like like an agenda going on right now I
feel like this whole pandemic thing was
kind of like a um it caused to a means
to an end and they want to kind of bring
about a certain change and this one
because
exactly
music
they they publicly say like covet is our
chance to change you know capitalism to
reform capitalism so it's like it
doesn't have to be a conspiracy it's
just a bunch of ideologues saying I'm
gonna do things in this direction yeah
right and then you end up with you know
six dollar gas in California people
fleeing like crazy nobody wants to live
there there's a saying that says from
all the chaos comes order so I think
this is like a a I would say this is a
made up agenda to push what they want
but control the money and control
control you know the food all the stuff
so I'll tell you guys what I'm doing
personally I'm like getting rid of all
my fiat currency I'm throwing it into uh
ethereum
Bitcoin uh real estate and then I even
bought some silver precious metals as
well yeah so I feel and then the next
thing I'm gonna do I don't know much
about the stock market I'm gonna get
into that as well get a trading get a
sorry broker account and then get into
that as well but yeah man if you ever
Diversified portfolio and you like take
your earned income and throw it into
assets man that's the best you could do
because I agree with you inflation is
gonna we're gonna pay for it soon if
these supermarkets are buying food right
now dude food spoils
so how long is this food Really Gonna
Last in their freezers couple months
they must be expecting some massive
inflation to hit within the next few
months or so so what what are these big
Supermarket chains know that we don't
where they're willing to bet on buying
tons of food that could spoil they might
never sell no they think they're going
to sell it which means are people gonna
be running out the door and buying up
food right now
like there's a lot of questions about
this
they buy larger amounts of frozen meat
how long is that really Gonna Last how
long can you freeze meat foreign
bought 10 loaves of bread yeah you could
only freeze them for so long it's not
going to be good right yeah and so
you're really expecting you're gonna eat
all that bread and you'd have to get the
worst bread not like the good stuff not
the Ezekiel you'd have to get like the
crappy white bread for it to last that
long right right it's really thin I like
Ian's bread Ezekiel is going to be green
in like three days yeah it makes bread
it spoils in a couple days because it's
just so fresh but but no check it out
check it out if these stores are buying
up all this food it sounds like they
think people are gonna be buying up all
this food soon why that freaks me out
that's a good point man it's like
something gonna happen people are
getting extra hungry or I'm gonna die I
like to eat organic oh yeah you're
totally gonna do it I'm dead no no no no
no that's the good news like
no no listen listen when all the food is
is is is you know gone or expensive you
need to eat the bugs fresh you know
fresh right out of the ground cicadas
are all gone so you can't do that
anymore roaches have protein yeah yeah
yeah dogs have a lot of protein man we
had a cricket bread I would say it was
underwhelming are we in Q3 right now did
we just enter fiscal quarter three no I
think we're in two okay so maybe they're
unloading their cash for quarter two
before uh the quarter ends try and
reduce but it's it's money and like
listen if if they think this is a move
to make money right because they're like
I'll put it this way if you can buy a
steak for a buck right now but next
month it'll be two bucks for that steak
they're saying like Okay I'm gonna buy a
bunch of steak now while it's cheap but
then you also gotta sell that steak very
quickly because it'll spoil so they're
not they're not only expect like they're
willing to take that that big of a bet
that prices are gonna are gonna be going
up relatively soon see six months I
think they know something that we don't
know because honestly this is a power
move here because why would you belt all
the food off rip so I think you're right
here but I don't know what the agenda is
here that's the thing that's a strange
risk yeah you know it's a good you know
it's a good investment what guns yeah
facts yes facts yeah I mean I was
thinking about this you mentioned real
estate crypto you know getting out of
Fiat I was thinking about that a little
while ago I was like
dude I've had a savings for a long time
I have some money that I have a savings
account and I'm just like I'm never
gonna touch this money and like it's
like I've had it for like a decade just
like sitting in the savings account and
I'm just and I look at it now I'm like I
can't buy anything with it anymore
but if I had used it a couple Grand 10
years ago I could have bought something
today man the inflation's been so crazy
the buying power is just like and I we
tell guys on our podcast you know like
you want to have at least six months a
year of like cash on hand you know for
immediate you know fiat currency like
that you that you can have access to but
everything else man throw it into like
assets because the dollar is going to
start you know then the inflation is
going to hit us very soon so I'll check
it out yeah but I agree with the guns
thing though because that is definitely
help in California I said date this
chick actually she was um she approved
the weapons permits in the Los Angeles
County she said she was a year behind
wow wow a year behind dude that's crazy
a year you know why you know why guns
are good though yeah think about it they
work for the most part you can just get
one you can put it in its case you can
seal it up and it's gonna work and it's
just a piece of metal yep but it's like
a good little piece of you know
engineering ammo too I think ammo yeah
but what I'm thinking about that I'm
like if I went out and bought a gun
right now and kept it properly stored
and the dollar goes down that that
that's that buying power of the value
within that weapon is going to keep
going up you're going to retain the same
value so I'm like that's a pretty good
investment like and also you got to
think about this too I love the
conspiracy theorists who are like you
know buy gold you know all the old Alex
Jones videos you got to buy your gold
people yeah I'm like what are you gonna
do with gold in an apocalypse like what
are you gonna do with gold if the
economy collapses nobody's gonna want it
yeah you're gonna it's good to have it
but like I agree like dumping out
because I know people that only do
precious metals and I'm like bro like
diversify you know what I'm saying but
uh yeah I agree like yeah what are you
gonna do I'll party in some gold if you
give me your Glock like what yeah right
like gold and silver will have value so
long as the economy still exists yeah so
the economy can tank not so bad and you
can see the price of gold go up or
silver go up that's why I do think it's
good to have some pressure miles I have
some
um I I do think it's good I think like
you said Diversified to have it yeah 100
ounces nothing crazy if the apocalypse
happened you know and like it was like
coveted times 10 nobody's gonna want
gold they're gonna want food water yeah
I don't know and protection yeah guess
what for the dating side of it you know
the best investment for dating what is
that cat food and dog food all these
Single Ladies
oh man not bad dude it was really hard
to get cat food
um even right now it's like it's been
difficult really yeah with all these
food shortages cat food's one of them I
don't know why they invented dry food uh
for dogs and cats like during World War
II because they had to repurpose all the
meat for the troops so for the first
time in history they stopped feeding
cats and dogs wet food and they created
this dry basically it's like giving cats
and dogs bread and a lot of times people
think it's because why you see feline
diabetes and diabetes and animals from
too much dry food just let them go
outside and eat some Critters yeah man
that's what meat that's what they're
built for yeah Buckle we let them
outside people got mad at us they were
like this is bad bad pet ownership
because he killed a rabbit and then we
saw him just like eating the rabbit on
the porch and it was like it was a big
rabbit he like chewed its head off
Natural Selection yeah and oh it's a cat
I don't know man we put a bell on them
so now when he runs it Jingles which is
supposed to help the animals Escape
because like bro we got clean food for
you here man what are you doing
but he wants to just he wants to murder
you know I did not know
there was uh you know cats bring you
dead animals
you know what yeah yeah they'll come
near if you have a pet cat and you let
him outside they'll come to you and drop
like a dead bird or or a mouse or
something in front of you to like give
to you and apparently they're telling
you you're a bad Hunter yeah you never
get mice and here I'm gonna show you so
what you're supposed to do or they're
like here I got this for you and yeah
what am I supposed to do with this crazy
eat it yeah but we got chickens though
and the chickens ate mice ugh there was
a mouse running along to the chicken
coop and a chicken just snatched it and
gobbled up in one one Chomp what yeah
like a chicken out of Roots Chicken what
the hell yeah I did not know that I saw
any corn and stuff like they do no no no
no no no no no they don't eat corn
chickens eat bugs you you chickens eat
everything actually grain too yeah but
um the the people think you feed chicken
seeds or anything you know if you let
chickens go they eat bugs they scrape
the ground and look for bugs that's what
chickens eat and so people like when you
give them corn and stuff it's like
giving them candy that's what that's
what the people at the store told me oh
wow that's how you fatten them up
probably too yeah yeah that's what they
feed the chickens you know and then for
like if your hands you know they're
laying they have a thing called a layer
egg layer and then they eat it and it's
like weird grainy protein garbage
apparently if you put a wooden egg in
there with the chickens they think that
it's egg laying season they'll lay more
eggs that's true yeah that's so weird
could you imagine if aliens put like a
fake baby in a hospital like I guess I
gotta have babies I could just check
people into doing that yeah what about
like uh deers because I see some in the
back oh yeah deers oh yeah dude they're
everywhere and I'm worried they're
always they're always stealing our
apples like they walk up to the tree and
they just reach up and grab them and I'm
like shaking my fist at them yeah yeah
people apparently they're pests yeah I
don't mind them they eat our mulberries
you see them like eating the mulberries
and I'm like whatever I don't like them
I never thought it tears this I didn't
think about that hey man you gave him
some carrots but I was nice of you I was
trying to but he ran off right away it
makes sense but they they kill him in
Texas oh yeah yeah they kill them all
the time oh it makes sense we'll have
like five or six in the yard at once
yeah and they you know I don't mind them
they don't do much other than I'm really
worried about them eating the pawpaw
because pawpaw are really really hard to
grow it's like it's like they call it
Hillbilly banana
yeah so cool yeah so they say it's like
a mango an avocado or something like
like avocado and banana or something
like that and so we have very few of
them because they're hard to grow and
you know I don't know they were saying
that the deer might come and snatch them
up so you like once they get ripened up
you got to be careful but someone was
telling me that the deer don't like them
anyway not to worry about it and I'm
like all right but I watch them I see
them walking towards that pawpaw tree
and then I open the window I'm like hey
hey get out of here
it goes and steals it anyway yeah so I'm
curious if you're an apocal if you were
in the apocalypse right what is one
animal you would want to have by your
side
a dog a dog a German Shepherd okay Ian
oh that's a tough one I have yeah I was
gonna go crazy and say a falcon but I
think it's odd I think you want a basic
falcon punch a hunting dog okay
Myron yeah you'd want a dog wait wait
wait wait like by my side yeah by your
side dude a gorilla a gorilla who would
you be able to control him though if
he's by my side like if you're saying
like he's my he's my dude yeah he's a
dude oh yeah dude okay
being homies with like just like a fully
grown gorilla if he's like a Pokemon I'm
like yo do psychics does it then I'm
cool with that but like you know are you
really gonna listen to me like yo
psychically look at me like nah bro but
if it was like uh
reality a dog of course yes
but do you guys what's your plan
alligator or something it's funny
because like um in Florida we have
alligators right yeah so my thing is hey
you come close to me let's go second boy
oh yeah alligator alligator crocodile I
don't know bro is it alligators or
crocodiles like I can't tell the
difference Crocs I have no idea I feel
like they're lazy I feel like they want
to do nothing they'd be like Yo Go
attacking me look at you like right but
if you could have an animal with you
that was like your animal that was cool
with you and listen to you you'd want
something big and powerful like a rhino
or something that is very true yeah
cause like you could just be like Chase
down or maybe a lion what about tiger
yeah or leopard if you had a
domesticated big cat if you could like
black panther
okay yeah that would be good but yeah
you definitely need Pokemon badges for a
tiger though yeah
you ain't gonna make it with just the
pewter gym badge bro
that dude had no game yeah he was like
uh how many people who listen to the
show watch Pokemon all that all that
dude would do is just like try it yeah
Rock Pokemon nobody would hit him you're
the worst Misty no I I don't mean I
don't mean like his Pokemon game I think
girls yeah oh yeah
he's so horrible
's like hey oh you're so beautiful he's
like bro get away from me yeah his eyes
were always closed yeah like so hot
chick bro
and he always had like three Geo dudes
and I'm like bro Geodude is trash why do
you have a jail you'll have a Geodude a
Golem and then gravatar oh and then
another Geodude another gravitar I'm
like bro you took an L with the first
three what makes you think the other
three are gonna win for you like what
like every Pokemon breed like destroys
you guys but you know except for
electric but you know surfing Pikachu
done finesse that was a dumb thing about
that show it was like
he electrocuted the Geo dude because it
got water on it or something like how is
that possible dude the show broke so
many rules yeah yeah like you know like
a Pikachu would beat a Geodude Reno damn
well that if like Joe dude use like
earthquake or something like did Pikachu
be dead dude anyone's actually played
the game is like what's Pikachu gonna do
quick attack and Tackle yeah and then
it's like doing one damage each turn and
you're like I'm just dying this is
pointless yeah why are we talking about
Pokemon I don't know I don't know I
don't know
apocalypse animals Pokemon yeah you
couldn't get a surfing Pikachu though
surfing Pikachu Pokemon Stadium uh 64.
yeah you had to do some stuff and then
you could teach your Pikachu sir I think
your child's loving the Pokemon
discussion right now so let's do this
we're gonna hard segue because yeah we
had a conversation last night about uh
critical critical race theory in schools
okay have you guys followed any of that
stuff it's funny we had a hotel we had
Hotel on it we were talking about it a
little bit Yeah so this is like I don't
know
I guess the maybe esoteric is the right
word it's kind of scary because more
people should pay attention to the stuff
but uh one of the things we talked about
in the bonus segment which maybe we'll
get into a bit more in the boxing for
this one as it pertains to dating and
stuff like this is um
how like the gender identity stuff is is
affecting future Generations
um people people aren't having families
anymore we talked a bit about climate
change I mean there's articles where
it's like having a child is one of the
most destructive things you can do to
the planet
the wrong way they could probably like
oh yeah effects want to destroy the
Earth yeah that's true yeah there'll be
a liability on not just you but like
Society in general let's let's do this I
know we talked about Pokemon for some
reason but we'll just we'll Pretend
We're segwaying from the Florida climate
change stuff into the dating stuff with
this story all right it's from 2017.
having children is one of the most
destructive things you can do to the
environment say researchers one fewer
child per family can save average of
58.6 tons of CO2 equivalent emissions
per year so you got stories like this
and then you've got um I think people
like AOC you know said I'm worried about
having kids because of the environment
you've got a lot of stories popping up
where people saying they're not gonna
have kids for political reasons and so
yeah yeah no joke man you look shocked
by this yeah this is stuff that we talk
about quite a bit Bill Gates do the
population I I think depopulation isn't
the right word no population management
they want to slow the growth of
population or stop it to a great degree
or control it right and so it starts
getting into scary conversations about
Eugenics you know choosing who gets to
have kids stuff but I don't know what
they're doing in that regard other than
you've got articles popping up this one
says researchers from London University
found having one fewer child could save
you know 58.6 tons eating meat driving a
car and traveling by airplane made up
the list of the most polluting things
people can do on the planet but having
children was top according to a new
study so you know I guess in terms of
where we're headed people don't have
kids people aren't they do have the
lowest birth rates yeah in the western
General how old are you guys I'm 31. 31.
I'm 28. do you guys are you guys married
with kids no hell no come on bro no
way man
it's funny yeah no but think about like
uh um I don't know about your parents
generation like how old my parents were
in their late 20s when they had multiple
kids yeah same my mom like 40 years old
yeah that explains a lot yeah yeah am I
stuttering
now but my grandparents man like they
worked together for like 70 years man
like back then it was more like you know
you find somebody you know you work
through the problems and you figure it
out now it is kind of like hey if you're
not benefiting me like what's the point
here so regarding kids it's kind of like
okay what's going to have kids with
somebody that you don't really trust so
you know that goes into trust you know
dating relationships so I just say
you're having kids is a big deal because
now it's two people together for a
lifetime and most people they want to be
for a reason or season but not for the
whole time so what's the point of having
kids
continue the Legacy I think it's more
eagle and if it I think it's more ego
bro honestly yeah what Eagle I mean
we're we're designed to procreate man
yeah yeah but like okay if you're living
life you're living a good life yeah why
do you want kids
well it's easy for us to say that now
but when you get older You're Gonna Want
Kids bro
you know just fortunately for us we can
like push the clock back longer yeah as
men you know what I'm saying as a guy
like you can you know you can keep doing
it until the day you die but like you
know for women they got a finite amount
of time because I hear it I want a
little mini me I'm like heck yeah what
do you want to Mini Me is it for your
own personal Gainer because you actually
want a kid to enjoy life that's some
questioning like okay is it about you
your ego or is it about the kid itself
yeah everyone has kids says it's the
best thing they've ever done so I I I I
I believe the hype but I'm not going to
do it until like I'm completely ready
because in today's day and age you know
you got to be very cautious about doing
it but that's why I think you know so
many people are putting children on the
back burner to pursue a career making
money but we're we're our parents ready
my mom was on vacation in Barbados when
she had me it was my other mistake hi
Mom
yeah but but isn't everybody like that's
why it's always funny when you watch on
uh TV shows and they say like a kid was
an accident or whatever I'm like come on
dude like most kids are accidents yeah
like nobody was like all right it's 7
P.M on the third uh it's time to have a
baby some people do it yeah some people
are like I want my kid to be born on
Christmas you know we time it perfectly
that's the worst day to be born to
because my friends who had birthdays on
Christmas they're gonna get any they got
one president
that's Christmas and your birthday
congratulations who's your president
have a nice day yeah everybody else got
presents exactly right Tim you're never
really ready for kids because like you
might prepare for it but it might happen
when it's time who knows so what's
what's the end result of this I mean
we're talking about inflation we're
gonna have if if we don't have more
people this this weird like are you guys
familiar with the economic system and
the Federal Reserve and all this stuff
yeah yeah it's not going to sustain
itself of course there's not more people
yeah so is going to take over
you said it oh yes
oh no
just put it bluntly I guess
I was a good run while
1.4 billion people or whatever so no but
I I honestly believe Matt at some point
in time we're gonna have a massive shift
where it's gonna be under one control
which is like the government the food
you know the money and it's kind of like
okay now that we control you know what's
needed in life like you have to do what
I say and the majority of people are
going to kind of follow a trend and if
you don't follow the trend you're gonna
be exercised from like you know the
whole society you know the current
system something in you know what China
think about their current setup they
hardly having any kids it's all business
and structure technology how to how to
expand how to build an Empire versus now
America's kind of like you know well
they want people to have kids now though
in China yeah yeah they got rid of that
rule one one kid per yeah family who
used to be a male but now the problem is
that they've almost over corrected the
point where like there's no women
anymore like there's doing too many too
many men too many Bachelors they buy
North Korean slaves oh is that what
they're doing yeah yeah we actually had
a woman from North Korea on the show and
she was saying like that's what they do
because there's no women so they just
buy them from North Korea oh I didn't
know that stuff yeah man the world's a
dirty place you know it's like it's
nasty stuff going on but my question
China's like we're going to win at any
cost you don't care do you actually want
to have kids in this current climate
right now do you really want to
have yeah but come on man people like
kids during World War II people had kids
during Vietnam you know Pete like the
world was messed up in a lot of ways
people still had kids I think we're
being inundated with propaganda like
this where they're like you can't have
kids the environment you know it's it's
really really bad and it's like
I mean that's that's that's true I
suppose like humans
fart and poop and eat and stuff like
that but people have kids
I wouldn't say the natural environment
is the problem like you know with you
know obviously pollution that plays into
it but I think it's more like raising a
kid in today's day and age in this
contemporary Marketplace like ah like
it's it's gonna be tough man like yeah
like I mean family you if the family
unit is not as strong as it used to be
you know nowadays you know you got
single moms all over the place uh you
know there's a whole bunch of things
which we get to cover later but yeah I
mean it's just it would be tough to
raise children now I know what's the
future gonna look like if we're not
having kids
I mean like we're not
trying to take it over man
I mean if we don't have kids anymore and
we're kind of like you know just you
know doing our thing
um it is selfish at the same time but I
understand why people do it my thing is
you don't have kids though it's kind of
like
we're going to be stuck in a certain
like mindset and um you know I would say
hysteria because now
we're not bringing up new ideas and new
people to think about certain things so
we're stuck in a certain like you know
box of okay it's what we think if you
don't agree with it that yeah you need
to propagate the Next Generation you
know and right now the birth rates are
the lowest they've ever been you know
and there's a bunch of reasons for that
you know you can feminism you know the
cost of living has went up inflation all
these other things but you know people
are millennials now they're less likely
to buy a home you know they'd rather
rent so there's a bunch of things you
know why I don't believe that rather
rent thing though no not that's that's
absurd like why would you rather rent I
so they can't buy that that's probably
especially with BlackRock yeah yeah
literally like our generation don't be
entrees and invest but they can't
they're working at Starbucks they're
working at how are you gonna invest with
that money so it's kind of tough I was I
mean but here's the thing man like I'm
like thinking like guys my age group
like very few of my friends actually own
a home they rent that's right like
that's what I'm saying like like uh guys
like in our age group like that I guess
would be considered millennials yeah
they're less likely to buy a home you
know but yeah I agree that yeah credit
is a part of it and then also they're
pushing back because I've always said it
like there's really no need to buy a
home unless you're gonna have kids
because then you're tied down to that
area and the only reason you would want
to be tied down to a geographic area is
for a good school exactly so I wouldn't
you know if you're a single guy or
you're even if you're in a relationship
with a woman you know together in a
monogamous relationship like unless
you're gonna have kids I wouldn't buy a
home because I think it's like not a
it's kind of throwing money you you lose
your leverage to be able to maneuver
around and do what you want to do
because you're now you're confined to
one geographic area on a house that's
not true no just go to Rental Management
Company
and then you buy let's say buy a house
and you okay and you live there for one
year like like you're gonna do a lease
then you decide I don't want to live
here anymore I want to deal with this
there's
probably hundreds or thousands of rental
management companies oh yeah if you rent
it out and you do it that's good but
what you want to think about it yeah but
mostly literally they're gonna keep the
house that's what I'm saying like a lot
of people you still own it so so what
happens is you buy a house you own it
you're paying less per month to live
there and then when you decide to leave
and go somewhere else you call a rental
management company you sign a paper you
walk away and you don't think twice you
don't even you don't even think about
the house anymore it's yours and then
all of a sudden every few months some
money appears in your bank account yeah
if it's if it's like for that where
you're going to rent it back out that's
great but a lot of people you know
they're not dark I would say they're
gonna buy the house and like live in and
be like I have a house you know yeah
like like the American dream you know
the white picket fence a home in a good
school district I can send my kids to
school you know that's why why a lot of
people buy a home from Eagle two as well
they're like oh this is my house this is
where I have things this is where I have
my parties so when they leave it's like
okay I'm leaving everything behind but
like are you saying you can do that as
an option yeah but majority of people
that I've seen in real estate community
that buy hotels and living right yeah I
don't think there's good schools anymore
though to be honest and that might be an
issue too I would say we're getting
there we're like this this pretty soon
you're going to just have to send your
kids to a private school or home school
we're going to get there to that point
very soon we're there now dude yeah we
had we had this uh uh umani on the other
day and she's working with a bunch of
parents targeting critical race Theory
and critical theory in schools the stuff
they're teaching kids man is just insane
mind-blowing you should just like the
books that she brought mind-blowingly
insane like what do you think
indoctrination on steroids yeah like
worse than college campuses yes yes it
was like the same so like the first
graders no like you you imagine like a
third like a work a worksheet for a
third grader is going to be like you
know a train leave Cincinnati going 50
miles an hour and then a train leaves
Chicago going 70 miles an hour like you
know math problems like that we're
looking at this workbook and it's like
what makes you uncomfortable in your
black skin what like asking a child that
and then having them write down but the
thing is it's a loaded question there
was like one of the questions no joke
was something like why do you think
black people are uncomfortable in their
skin that was like one of the questions
Shaggy and I was like what but you see
other questions loaded like it's
asserting it as true yeah yeah and so
the kid has to believe that's asking you
why you think it's true yeah right right
asserting it is true and there was one
it was like how can you be a better uh
what'd it say gender race what is gender
race or racial it's just it's just
psychobabble oh dude if that's the case
then yeah
obviously I went to school in the 90s
right so like back then you know you
were still you know coloring in circles
and stuff like oh don't mess outside the
line and you know playing Tic-Tac-Toe
and you know maybe you know again in
some fights in the schoolyard whatever
it is but like now if that stuff's going
on that's a clown World bro yeah yeah I
did not realize that the school system
has changed that much that's what that's
why I asked question do we do we really
want to have kids in this current
climate I I mean honestly home school is
the only way I would actually do it uh
that's the only way I would I would do
it honestly homeschool man for sure but
the negative to that is that like you
kind of want them to be around other
kids too yeah that's that's think one of
the beauties of like sending your kids
to public school is like they build a
friend group they learn how to interact
with other people they learn like what's
socially acceptable what isn't you know
I think bullying is good personally like
but like I grew up I got bullied as a
kid and it made me a better man you know
I like it it like kind of it if you were
a weirdo or whatever like you'd get
picked on four but then you would know
man maybe I shouldn't act like this or
whatever it kind of some people make
some some people break some right but
you know it lets you know just bring
your kids to the skate park you could do
that too and there's a bunch of other
kids we'll get them involved in sports
yeah get them involved in sports bring
them out in to public spaces community
events play an instrument these the
problem with these schools is you don't
actually know what they're teaching your
kids and you can't just give that
responsibility to strangers yeah and
that was that was a mistake people you
know parents made for a long time
because even you know even outside of
the indoctrination of weird culty
ideologies and like racist garbage
college campuses are awful right now
yeah do we hear stories about like a dad
who's like I sent my 18 year old
daughter to college she came back hating
me and her hair was her head was shaved
she was wearing weird clothes and her
face was all pierced up you're toxically
masculine dad you know yeah yeah it's
crazy man it's a clown world but
um yeah with kids I mean if it's like
that let me let me let me let's talk
about let's let's talk about the other
aspect of this yeah sure you know the
future and everything is obviously the
dating stuff which you guys you know get
into a lot but I got a theory for you
guys I'm learning though that I I have
no kids all right cool so I'm sure you
guys have talked about something related
to this because you probably talk about
date you do talk about dating more than
we do so uh I think dating apps and and
dating websites are one of the reasons
why people aren't having kids it's
probably a really big reason and one and
there was also a study that came out
that found something like a third of
people under the a third of men under 29
are virgins so the reason I think for it
is back in the day kids are in college
right yeah 18 year olds go to college
these young 18 year old women they only
know the people in their college so
probably up to 22 maybe 24 maybe an
older college professor ooh that was
taboo but for the most part they're
going to parties with people similar in
age to them now uh with dating apps they
just open up an app and there's a 35
year old guy who's got a car who's got
his own apartment and she swipes right
on him he's like oh he's got he's got a
convertible then she sees a 20 year old
guy who's at her college and she swipes
out on him she thinks he's attractive
she gets two messages the 20 year old
college student guy says you want to
come hang out at my dorm with me and my
friends and watch Netflix the 35 year
old guy says you want to hop in my
converter convertible we'll go drive to
my lake house and chill out in the
infinity pool which one's she gonna pick
yeah she's gonna pick the older guy I
mean we could break this down like we we
have theories on exactly why this is
going down the way it is but sorry no no
that's it yeah yeah so what do you think
um you want to take it first BBD you go
off
okay you first no you go first no I won
I don't know no no no I won I see you go
first okay man you had paper so
basically right uh you're right because
right now we're in a social media age
where you can see what was the number in
front of you before so what's happening
is like you said earlier girls are on
platforms like Instagram you know
they're on Facebook they're also on like
you know Tick Tock and you're seeing
these these these very uh I would say
affluent guys with you know a lifestyle
that they want to be a part of versus
the guy at college is kind of like okay
let's go party in the dorms let's get
lit but it's kind of what she did
already so now she's open up the whole
new world and she might be in Idaho
or even Texas whatever and a guy says
hey I'm in La I'm in Miami come out to
see me and let's get lit now that's a
whole new world to her and she's excited
so I would say girls like lifestyle know
more than anything else and now they can
actually see it through social media and
they want to be a part of it however
most guys that are young are in school
they don't have that lifestyle they
don't have that abundance so I just hey
you know what let's go here there
everywhere because obviously they're
still in school they don't have a lot of
money saved up the point being here is
that like girls don't have huge access
to people that they've never had before
and the problem is that like there's no
like buffer for guys that are like up
and coming so they choose the better the
bigger better deal BBD there was a uh
some posts from Mike you guys know Mike
cernovich yes yeah he he was posting
about how and at the highest level of
dating the most attractive men it's like
guys on Instagram with successful
accounts and they're super rich and
they're super desirable and what they do
is they just see an Instagram account
for uh for a you know an attractive
woman and then just DM her and be like
hey yo we got reservation at this this
fancy restaurant you want a table you
want you want an invite right and
they're like yeah and then they're
hanging out with Rich successful
attractive dudes whereas dating apps
that's that's just for mediocre people
that's what he was saying like he was
wasting their time on that it's funny
because we have an Instagram course yeah
because we believe Instagram is a no
more dating platform in the world right
and we say all the time hey you put up a
good Instagram page that's your new
resume so now they can see your
lifestyle who you really are and before
you just have dating apps or whatever
and it's like so pictures maybe a bio
and that's it now look at your stories
your highlights everything in between so
with these guys hey you know what
instead of relying on dating apps do
everything but Instagram no you have
leverage return it turns like you can go
on the explore page you can find girls
there you can hit them up randomly you
can go like let's see one go to Columbia
right I can put in hashtag Columbia in
the search bar from deck of finding a
list of girls that tag that same
location I say you know what I'm going
to Columbia in two weeks let's go get
some drinks and party there you go and
you do that to 20 people or the 20 10 I
respond or that 10 you might see five
but before you even get there it goes
lined up for you all free that's
powerful because social media and scale
so I'm just saying for guys nowadays if
you want to have the most options
possible get on Instagram or some
platform like that the social media
driven that's the large base you can go
anywhere in the world you can do a
location like I said Colombia Brazil
wherever you want to go and you can find
what you want that but that being said
nowadays even even on a good profile
you're kind of losing out on a lot of
access to girls I would say so
um so I'll break this down from A to Z
let's go so why why this is happening
because what you mentioned is basically
like a byproduct of the current dating
Marketplace we have now which is
basically a globalized sexual
Marketplace just like the world is
globalized um the dating Marketplace has
become globalized as well and what's
happened is to understand this well we
got to know first the right for the guys
out there that might not be familiar
with us we talk about something called
hypergamy right which is like women
dating up wanting a man that's uh you
know better than them in different
facets of life you know typically it's
you know they want the provisioning on
security one end but they also want an
attractive guy that's physically
attractive as well from a height
standpoint jawline physique Etc so and
Shout throughout tomasi talks about this
book and talks about this in his book
the rational mail the two sides of
hypergamy so in today's day and age with
the globalized marketplace girls have
more options than ever before so if a
girl's on a dating app women have all
the leverage on dating apps because
almost 80 of the users on dating apps
are men so supply and demand there's far
more men far fewer women so the women
can be selective so even girls that
aren't necessarily as attractive have
higher standards now because they have
the ability to do so and not only that
they have also have Instagram like fresh
was saying Instagram is really the
number one dating app in the world and
if a girl has a moderately attractive
profile she's going to get DMS and
messages from all types of guys that you
mentioned before guys with blue check
marks guys that are athletes guys that
are celebrities whatever it is they're
hosting parties and what's happened is
with the way the world is now a woman
that was in let's say Idaho we always
like to use the state Idaho right in the
middle of nowhere she's attractive in
her local area the guys that would have
been potential good mates those guys are
now invisible to her because she's
getting hit up by higher status men in
LA in Miami in uh Vegas whatever and
I'll travel to that guy you know it's
going to be way more fun I'll go hang
out with him he has money he has
resources he has a cool lifestyle you
know we always say women trap with their
with their thirst trap with their bodies
meant their strap with their lifestyle
and that's what Instagram allows people
to do so women since women day up and
they want the bigger better deal they're
not going to settle on a guy that's just
good enough if they can get something
better so what's happened is
since women have an abundance of options
they just pick at the top and if you go
through any attractive woman's Instagram
you're going to see a whole bunch of
blue checks celebs whatever it is and
these are average women getting this
type of attention so what happens the
average guy gets kind of left out on the
dust and this is why so many men uh in
the age group that you're saying from
like 18 to 29 are virgins and we
actually talk about on our podcast that
if you were to take
um virgins in 2021 I would be willing to
bet a majority of them would be men and
not women and women there's a study that
came out uh there is an increase in
virgin women but it's substantially less
the increase in men under the age of 29
who are virgins is really it skyrocketed
to like a third yeah it was like 20 some
percent now it's 30 or something like
that no no it was way bigger than that
it was like in the teens and then just
doubled and then for women it wasn't
even that big of a jump but it did go up
yeah and we say all the time you know
some people disagree or whatever but
from what we're seeing women typically
want the top 10 to 20 of men and they're
getting those are the guys that are
having uh relations with most of most of
the women and it's actually very funny
because on our podcast one of the
questions we like to ask just to kind of
get a gauge of the room the temperature
hey ladies what percentage of men do you
think are actually you know active
active right to keep a YouTube friendly
and they're always like oh 70 80 90 100
they're all banging and we're like no
only like maybe 10 to 20 of men are like
having all the girls and when you say
that they're like shocked like what and
it just goes to show I tell guys all the
time women don't live in the same
reality that we do a lot of the times
you know they kind of have dating on
easy mode and they're not used they
don't even see a lot of guys a lot of
men are invisible to them because if
they don't meet a certain metric and
they've their social media online dating
whatever it's created this illusion of
abundance almost to to a um to a fault
yeah so that's what's kind of been going
on there there was another study where
they asked men and women to write
attractiveness of you know women to men
men to women and they saw that Tinder
study yeah it was the one was it the one
where they found that uh men rate women
on an even scale where it's like the
ugly women are ugly and the average
women are average and the hot women are
not but women rate men on extremely
imbalanced scale where eighty percent of
men are unattractive and only the
hottest men are attractive absolutely
like 88
um it's either Okay Cupid or Tinder that
they pulled that from but yeah and the
reason why is because um women are far
more selective on online dating apps
because they have the leverage like
um there's far more men and far less
women and on top of that the apps the
only person that really the person that
loses the most with online dating apps
like tender Bumble Etc is really the men
because for the guy for you to be able
to get a quarter of the access that
women have you have to pay for some kind
of subscription service to be able to
swipe more to be able to you know run
the numbers because anyone that's good
with women will tell you it's a numbers
game you know top guys in the world
close maybe 10 of their leads and you
know whether you're meeting her through
online dating cold approach during the
day cold approach during night Instagram
whatever it is a guy that's top tier
closes 10 and when I say that women
think I'm speaking Chinese it's like no
it's actually very difficult for men and
then on an online dating app where they
have all the leverage it's even tougher
so one of those tell guys you need a
good Instagram account as well to
augment your online dating profile
because on a bounce of probabilities if
she swipes on you she's still going to
think you're corny to some degree or not
really finding that attractive so you
have to augment your entire how do I say
this it's like a sales page yeah you
want a rude awakening go to your friends
your heart girlfriend's Instagram DMS or
a friend of a friend's DMS look at her
DMS you're going to see blue check marks
you're going to see athletes everything
in between and go to Africa's dams you
can see the same thing there's no uh big
skill here a big change they're all
being hit up with these celebrities and
it's kind of like okay how do you
compete with that you can't yeah no
matter what you do you can't so all you
can do is level up the best you can
Fitness mindset lifestyle be the best
person you can be and at that point
leverage social media yeah you guys ever
watch King of the Hill yes you ever see
that episode where Hank asks uh he's
like he asks Boomhauer to teach Bobby
how to how to how to pitch woo you know
this one no so he's like Boomhauer is
like good with the ladies like boom how
will you teach Bobby even though no one
understands them
so he he takes Bobby to the shoe store
and then he's like all right Bobby I'm
gonna teach you how to pick up women and
then boom Howard walks into the woman
and goes hey girls going to give me that
number that he dropped up some time and
then she's like she slaps him and then
he walks into another room and he goes
hey damn girl looking pretty good you're
gonna give me that number I hit you up
sometime and then she like slaps him and
then he keeps doing it and then he
finally gets a number yeah and he walks
up he's like look at that Bobby I got a
phone number right there and then
Bobby's like that's the secret Mr
Boomhauer you just ask every woman and
he goes come on that's secret but that
was it yeah Boomhauer just asked every
single woman until he finally got a
number remember I think I'm crazy so in
Miami right um when I first moved there
back in 2018 I used to do something it's
called night game right but like when
you go out at night to the clubs bars
whatever to see me girls right I used to
go one for 40 man and people think like
what you're talk to 40 girls to find one
that like wanted to leave which I was
like yeah bro it's tough because like
when you go out at night you're playing
like on Ultra hard mode you know what I
mean because the music is loud bouncers
are trying to you know you know CBU uh
keep you too friendly you know you got
the friends that are trying to CBU you
got to pay for drinks you know there's a
bunch of things that are distract and uh
can hurt you in in that kind of Arena
but I enjoyed it it was fun it was when
I first moved to Miami in 2018 but it
takes a lot of work because you got a
cold approach a bunch of girls figure
out which ones want you which ones don't
and then the biggest thing is a lot of
girls just like attention right a lot of
women like to sit there and talk with
you and get your non-sexual attention so
you got to be able to like kick those
girls to the curb immediately let's get
the feminine I saw angry right now oh
sure let's do it let's go the the ones
the one story that I always bring up
that always triggers like this wave like
I'll see my name trending after I after
I talk about it I'm like okay you know
whatever I don't care
um as women start making more money
men who make as much money as them are
unattractive oh and so we have this we
have a study lack of economically
attractive men to blame for decline in
marriage rates studies suggests this is
a big story in 2019. yeah and there was
a there was another story from the New
York Post talking about women in their
30s struggled to find men who make as
much money as them and the funny thing
about it
the story about uh women not being able
to find men to make as much money as
them it's like the initial assumption
was where are all the good men like why
is it so hard for a woman in her 30s who
makes 50 000 a year to find a man who's
equal to her and the issue is they seem
to think these men don't exist that's
not the case it's that if you're a 35
year old woman who makes 50 000 a year
and you're like you know a manager at a
business of some sort
a man who's 35 years old who's a manager
who makes 50k is not trying to date you
he's trying to date a 22 year old
I'm not saying that's a good thing I'm
not I'm not passing judgment or
criticizing women I'm saying quite
literally dudes want to date young women
and it's like we were mentioning just a
moment ago in the previous segment about
how you know uh these guys who have
careers and have cars and have
apartments are on dating apps or
Instagram and they can hit up this
college student or a chicken Idaho who's
like you know now she's she's accessed
she has access to every man so this this
35 year old guy is not trying to hook up
for the most part or at least I should
say is a tendency so then you end up
with women upset they can't find
economically attractive men and then you
end up with the study talking about
divorces that when uh men don't make
more money than the woman the women
don't like want to be in the women don't
want to be in the relationship anymore
yeah um and this is an uncomfortable
reality for women and the thing is is
that women got to understand that men
have standards too it's just that when
hey I know it's shocking right upstairs
because like the thing is this if woman
says I want a man that makes a certain
amount of money a hundred thousand
dollars a year since to be what most
women wants six feet tall attractive
whatever confidence that's okay that's
considered preferences but if a man says
I want a woman that's young attractive
and not annoying or crass that's
considered discrimination and that's the
problem and a lot of women don't
understand this because if a man speaks
his mind of what he really likes in
women he can get canceled be called a
misogynist whatever it is so very few
men tell the truth about what they're
attracted to in women and the reality
ladies I'll tell you
the more the more money you make and the
older you get the less negotiating power
you have in the relationship world
because the things that make a woman
attractive are not the same things that
make a man attractive women think a lot
of the times tend to base their value on
masculine traits how much they earn
their career Etc that is asinine that's
like me saying Hey listen I look really
good in some heels I can walk in a dress
and as a matter of fact I'm really
feminine every girl would be repulsive I
told her she's like oh no that's that's
not what I'm into that's exactly how men
feel when a woman says I'm a career
woman I'm strong and independent it's
just that men rarely voice this because
to say that you're immediately going to
be hit with some kind of Shame language
so most guys don't voice what they
really want in women and they just act
on it instead what happens older women
get left on left uh left in the dust and
the men that they actually want to make
money have status Etc they go for
younger more attractive girls because
men are attracted to Youth and Beauty no
matter what Society wants to say reality
does not adhere to social constructs I
have to say this all the time to like
Angry feminist reality does not adhere
to social constructs just because you
have a degree and you make money that's
cool nothing wrong with that but
understand it's not going to increase
your sexiness by having a career and
here's what we hear a lot of it you
always try to there's always some
defense like um imagine if a dude you
mentioned looking good in heels or
whatever I think imagine if a dude said
my goal is to be a stay-at-home dad and
raise kids you know I don't want to be
in the workplace I want to get married
and have kids at a young age
that's not attractive I mean there are
certainly women who find that attractive
of course there's no absolutes there's a
lot of different people with different
preferences but it's a tendency you say
something like that oh they get it this
is what triggers the feminists Tweet
about it because guys want to go off on
adventures guys want to go hunting guys
want to accomplish that goal they don't
want to be stuck at home they want to be
you know it's different obviously there
are guys that do they're guys I wish I
could spend more time with their kids
and there are people who are upset they
spend too much time in the office but
there are Tendencies so if you're if if
you're uh put it this way The House
Always Wins right you know why the house
always wins in a casino because the odds
for say roulette or for for for craps is
51 in The house's favor yep which means
over a long enough period of time you
will lose you can maybe go in throw that
dice out one time get lucky and win the
jackpot but that's the exception not the
rule when it comes to dating even if
it's just 51 percent of men who don't
like this and 51 of women who don't like
that that's a pressure where you and the
the dating Marketplace will keep
experiencing this and you'll say why is
it so hard for me to find a guy who just
wants to be a stay-at-home dad or a guy
who says why is it so hard to find a
woman who just wants to be the CEO of a
company to be my wife I got a perfect
segue for that you just said something
magical which I have to say on the
podcast as you guys know on our show we
bring ladies into the show a lot of
career women a lot of women that are
entrepreneurs and they ask us how do I
land a guy like this or they just you
know they toss me to the side whatever
the problem is that a lot of women don't
understand that concept you just said
a lot of women operate on possibilities
instead of probabilities and the reality
is the probability is when you have a
lot when you make money you're
successful you're a strong independent
woman and you're in your 30s the
probability that you're going to find a
attractive man that makes as much money
as you if not more is confident attract
all these traits women typically want
and Men the probability is low but the
problem is this
I'm gonna say it a lot of women live in
a Disney fairy tale okay women are told
life is all good sugar and spice and on
top of that privileges are visible to
those that have it if a woman was
attractive in her 20s and late teens and
was getting attention from men she's
going to continue to think I will
continue to get the same attention and
validation from men into my 30s but they
don't realize until they're in their 30s
and they don't they're not necessarily
as attractive they can't compete right
on what men actually want Youth and
Beauty then that's when the reality hits
them and they operate on possibilities
well you know what it's still possible
for me to get my prince charming my uh
my prince but they don't realize that
that possibility is very slim and Men
fortunately for us we live in a
fact-based reality when it comes to
dating men know deep down you must
create if you don't create you're not
going to procreate period but women you
know they don't realize it until later
on that I work so hard for my career and
I can't get a guy but no you're using
masculine traits and now you've pretty
much pissed away your ability to have
that negotiating power to get a high
status guy have you ever seen the uh the
marketplace value study I think it was
okay cute but that did this and I think
they deleted a lot of these because
it was offensive to the woke but what it
shows is that
women start off young women have the
maximum possible societal value in terms
of what humans are willing to protect
and defend young young women start off
at 100 that's that's the line young men
guess where they start zero below zero
yeah well it's just the bottom it's like
on a scale of zero to 100 men are at
zero when young men are at zero why well
they're younger so they're not as
attractive they're not typically
masculine and and you know they're not
ripped they're not chiseled they haven't
had any money they don't need status
they've earned nothing they're starting
from the bottom why would anyone want
that rarely with young women however and
this is mostly due to to biology whether
anyone wants to believe it or not this
is what the studies show and I'm not
saying it's a good thing I'm just saying
men are attracted to young women for
their ability to to procreate they're
attractive they want to have kids they
want to have families what happens is
over time
Men start to become more valuable by
earning status making money collecting
resources and women start to become less
societally valuable again I'm not saying
it's a good thing
um because they're getting older and
their ability to to have kids is
dwindling and diminishing eventually
there's a Nexus point there's like a
point at which many I think it's around
30 yes or men and women they start to
intersect they even out and then what
happens is women go down and Men start
going up so men who are in I I think it
might have been cernovich was saying
this could be wrong like tomasi has a
graph on it that shows us access which
is like the women's Prime is like 18 to
24 right and then a man is typically in
their 30s you know like 35 to 50 or
something yeah 35 to 50. the thing is is
that a woman's value it shines the
hardest and brightest but it's for a
smaller period of time for men if they
do the work of course you know if you if
you're 35 years old and you're broke it
don't matter but you know if you if you
do the work you're you're you can uh
Shine for a longer period And I want to
stress too this is not a personal
opinion of value this is a number based
on the study I'm referring to looked at
messages who was getting hit up on
dating on dating websites and it wasn't
so much as to say like I think they
outlined this they're saying we're not
saying people are more or less valuable
as human beings worse than in the dating
World women get messages at a declining
rate from 24 and then onward men get an
increasing amount of message as as time
goes on but there was also another funny
metric in that where they found that
women tend to message men equal to their
age men always message 22 year olds yeah
it's it's uh and I know that study
you're talking about the university
between men between the ages of 18 all
the way to 60 almost always prefer women
between the ages of 18 to 24. you know
it's like it's 22 was like the number
yeah it was like the age of the man is
going up and the woman is just at 22 the
whole time yeah we had a 35 year old
woman on the show right late night show
and she was saying like yo I wish
someone told me these things when I was
younger because she was going out to the
club and it's like she's seen it 22
years old getting picked up by guys you
know getting hollered out she's like wow
I'm not getting the same attention and
it's kind of like she understood if she
had choose that time back you know back
then which is like in her 20s properly
she could probably locked on a man that
she cared about her now it's kind of
like okay I messed up those years of my
life I'm 35 years old what do I have
left to give and your youth isn't there
and guys want you there's nothing
problem is that like girls don't really
know what men really want and Men I
would say men kind of know what women
want but it's kind of like they are
putting themselves in the Box saying hey
you know what I can have fun in my 20s
get lit travel men can afford to try to
figure it out women can't they can't
that's the difference like like hit the
wall like like men like you could take
10 to 15 years to figure it out yeah and
come into your Prime later on women
don't get that benefit you know like and
the thing is is that like I said they
like to measure their value in masculine
standards which is asinine because
that's like me saying I can fit just
like I said earlier if I could wear
heels and walk in a dress you should
like me too and that's how women sound
when they say I have a career yeah they
based off masculine traits but you know
attractiveness matters but I think you
you know what you're saying about
masculine traits is is what I think
triggers feminists so severely yeah
definitely yeah the reason why like this
is the one video where it's like all of
a sudden I see all these women is
tweeting about me is because they were
told their whole lives you need to get a
career you need to be the CEO you need
to break the glass ceiling and so
they're like okay that's what I got to
do then they hit their third they're in
their 30s and they are in that senior
level position or the VP position and
they're like I did it now how are my
prospects for the things I want and guys
are like oh I respect you but I don't
want to have a family with you exactly
and that must be like getting smacked in
the face with a bag of bricks see if you
could find men who do for sure but as
you already stated like what ends up
happening is women then have to start
lowering their standards to find a man
who's going to be and they will not do
it we won't do it from the show women
will never submit they'd rather die
alone with dogs and cats than submit to
a guy that they don't want and here's
the scary part they've been lied to like
you said their whole life so now is that
okay they're awakened to us the truth
and it's like I don't I'm finding
because I don't I don't want to submit
but here's problem though you have to
because that's your only way out now
because you waited too long to close
that Gap so I'm just saying for women
out there like if you hear this right
now you're young
take it for what it is because if you
don't you wait too long to find this man
to settle down with in your 30s it's
kind of like okay well he's gonna choose
you over the 22 two girl why and I'll
say this too for the women out there
that want to chase a career and
everything I'm not saying don't chase a
career and don't make money just know
the consequences of that are you're
going to have a smaller pool of suitable
candidates that meet your requirements
and on top of that it's not going to
increase your sexual market value your
money does not equal come into that like
it does for a man so
chase her career but you should also be
working on trying to find a guy as well
and the thing is that women prioritize
chasing a career and they don't actually
prioritize like being a good girlfriend
or being a good wife or being a good
partner for a man and they're going to
put their career over that and the thing
is is that you have the most negotiating
power and ability to lock down a high
status man that you want when you're
young and attractive not later on
they're not trying to be what men want
they're trying to be what Society has
told them to be yeah and so you can keep
saying social contract over and over and
over again but the reality is guys you
look at okay Cupid's data and they
behave a certain way by all means
feminists you're allowed to insult those
men I when I did the segment they were
like you know Tim pool is basically
saying that men are losers who are
immature and I'm like fine I don't care
I'm not saying it's wrong I'm saying if
that's what you believe you're allowed
to believe that you're allowed to be
upset that men don't want to date you
just recognize that's what the data
shows and I'm not saying it's a good
thing but it's literally the studies
come out from several different Outlets
saying guys want 22 year olds they don't
care about career in fact salary is bad
high paying women men don't like it
right for whatever reason and women when
this is what we find in the study when a
woman makes six figures she won't want
to stay in a relationship with a man
who's making the same amount or less
than her yep I'm not saying it's all
women and I'm not saying it's a good
thing that's just what the studies come
out they show I'll take it a step
further yeah career women the least
happy demographic or female I think it
was a study from 2011 of human being
actually 42 year old woman unmarried no
children in a career yep that is the
least happy demographic of human being
and I've said this before on the podcast
you guys could say it's controversial or
not I say women don't derive this derive
the same pleasure and uh fulfillment
from careers and earning money that men
do men are built to work hours and go
through adversity and earn and bring it
home to a family women are not and
that's why just like you said before the
reason why so many women divorce a man
if they make more money than them or
whatever is because when you're the
breadwinner it inadvertently puts you in
a leadership position within the
relationship and I've said on the
podcast before women are incapable of
Leading Men within the confinements of a
relationship and as an matter of fact if
you put on that leadership role she's
going to lead you all right to the end
of the relationship because women are
not built to lead or provision long term
for men period let's let's get more
offensive to the feminists let's do it
we got the story this is from Daily Mail
women reveal how their appearances have
dramatically changed since they met
their Partners saying Comfort eating
birth control and babies have completely
altered their bodies
this this is in many ways the purpose of
marriage young women and young men
getting together and having a contract
to each other under God till death do us
part because they didn't because back in
the day it's a problem if a dude
continues continuously becomes more
valuable and more attractive and the
woman doesn't and then you end up with a
bunch of angry women and you end up with
a bunch of philandering men or
womanizing men to have structure they
said okay we'll do marriage well
nowadays divorce marriage is meaningless
there was a meme where it was like
it was a guy in his knee with a ring and
he says will you enter into a government
contract with me that you're allowed to
break at any time and if you do you get
half my stuff and she says yes yes a
million times yes it's like if that's
the that's the mentality that we have
this today there's there's there's no
guarantee in marriage why would anyone
do it back in the day if you tried to
get divorced the judge would be like I
sent into marriage counseling like you
can't you've got to figure it out and
you guys have have a mutual agreement
with each other you've got a family
you're going to raise it and it made
sense so today
I think this is a good example of
why there was marriage you got images of
these women
I'm just gonna I mean these are posts
they show themselves being a size six
meeting my BF and here's her two years
later as a 12 to 14 due to contraception
and eating bad food the first few months
of uh after uh meeting him so now she's
she's you know getting overweight here's
one where she's like here's me first me
my BF and now here's here's her now to
be fair this one she's actively pregnant
so I don't think that's actually fair to
criticize her here's one where she's
like here's how I look I'm fat there
there are a ton of women
celebrities or otherwise who have kids
and then go work out and get fit get
back in shape because they're they're
trying to look good and there are a lot
of women that look really really good as
soon as they get married that's the
Trope they let they let themselves go
that's why is it that in TV shows they
have that Trope of letting themself go
so I'll say this right think about this
you play a game right and let's say
you're playing level one okay you're
doing whatever you need to do to make
level two
at the last stage level 10 is a boss
right at the boss fight you put all the
stops you upgrade your weapons you
finally use your potions exactly exactly
so you have the last legendary weapon
you slay the the boss now you finish the
game you're not putting anyone ever into
the game because you already won the
game same thing with the relationships
with these women they find a guy that
they can lock down that can take care of
them and they put all the effort into it
at the beginning to get get a guy yeah
they got a guy who's like okay if I
leave I get to have his stuff and I'll
be good so I can do whatever I feel like
because now he's under my frame so I
feel like marriage itself Church in
store
um definitely has a place for women to
strive but for men it's a very
detrimental thing to do because you can
and and I I I won't say this right so
women have the advantage because they
can leave anytime and get what they want
but the guy if he leaves he's gonna lose
so I'm just saying in that situation
they have all the leverage and just them
just being there uh they can win and do
whatever they feel like because now they
like I said before they get everything
and that's it I think the prenuptial
agreement should be automatic and that
you should have to file to do away with
it the idea that there is no prenup
going into it and that everything you
used to own is now half owned by that
person because of the signage is insane
to me here's the problem though prenups
don't always work and if you do do a
prenup let's say they can say it was
under duress you know he forced me to do
it so they can also with the their way
out my thing is okay why even get this
pisses me off bro because it's kind of
like I understand why women leverage sex
Against Humanity marriages because they
can because think about it if you leave
your wife and you've been together for
10 years alimony child support all these
things come into play and you're stuck
there so my thing is uh these women can
take advantage because the law allows
them to so how do you avoid this don't
get married so here's here's a really
interesting uh tidbit we mentioned this
in a previous segment one of uh a large
component a large factor in divorces is
the woman making more money than the man
the man is no longer attractive when
he's not economically attractive because
like you guys mentioned what are women
are looking for lifestyle status
confidence so if they're in a
relationship and the woman is making a
bunch of money I have the story for
market watch they actually they actually
say they frame in a very funny way they
say this one thing in your marriage
increases the risk of Divorce by 33
percent and they're basically and they
show the image when the man is making
more than the woman things are good when
the woman's making more than the man
things are bad basically when the man is
no longer attracted to the woman she
leaves what about these guys that
they're in a relationship this woman
says she beat the game she gets she lets
herself go she has an exercise she
doesn't eat right anymore now she's
overweight unattractive it's it's it's
it's wrong for the guy to be like I'm
not attracted to this anymore you've
you've you've you know broken your
agreement with me here's the problem
um and I've said this on the show many
times and I'll say it I'm gonna probably
trigger some feminists right now but the
thing is this
women want traditional men but they
don't want to necessarily be traditional
women they want a guy that saw them
makes more money than them confident
attractive Etc if someone breaks into
the house he can handle it and protect
her and be willing to die for her right
but she ain't gonna make him a sandwich
oh you toxic misogynist make your own
sandwich so they want to be modern women
when it suits them but they want to be
traditional when it suits them as well
and that's the problem that's why we
tell guys don't get married nowadays
don't put yourself in a situation where
the woman has all the leverage because
when she has a leverage bad things are
going to happen and we know it because
look at it 80 of divorces are initiated
by women so you see what happens when
women have leverage they leave and
here's the other thing like as a man you
have a burden of performance men don't
ask for much from women women ask far
more of men than men ask of women so my
thing is something simple like bedroom
fun will keep a YouTube friendly right
how many sexless marriages are there out
there or Worse yeah I see on Tick Tock a
wife saying you're not going to get any
unless you take out the trash uh you're
not going to get any unless you mow the
lawn blah blah blah but if someone
breaks into the house you're expected to
protect this woman with your life and
she don't even want to give you no
bedroom fun that's BS that's why we tell
guys most of the time unless you want to
have kids you shouldn't get married at
all because women get in line when they
know that you have other women in line
that's why we tell guys to not date
exclusively it's a date not exclusively
you know let's let's think about the the
actual math of this of the situation
sure it sounds like feminism has been
the greatest gift to to
um
feminism has actually reverted Society
back to a more primitive State yes yes
yeah because of feminism I would say
it's the greatest like I said high value
men guys who are confident successful
wealthy they can get any woman they want
whatever they want with no obligations
no commitment and better yet half the
time the women are are working careers
and doing and doing a bunch of the work
so there was a meme where a feminist was
like or it was a meme where someone a
woman said feminism is a trick you guys
the men are gonna sit around playing
video games all day while they make us
do all the work right but so it's a joke
but what ends up happening is
you look back at how things used to be
in the tribal sense the the alpha male
the high value man would you know
whatever woman he wanted all of them all
of them and if you look at how uh in the
animal kingdom you know typically it's
like the most dominant powerful male
like you know takes all the women teen
wives roosters got like 12 ladies they
take it they fight each other they kill
the other one and they take their harem
so right now because of all this like
you mentioned these guys going to on
Instagram and they can just DM 50 women
and get back five messages and then one
of them is a go yep and that's what I've
said it before what feminism feminism is
actually done is has given all the
sexual leverage to the highest tier men
inadvertently to the unbeknown to them
they've basically given all leverage to
the men that will never actually commit
to them and what happens is the guys
that are you know good husbands good
potential long-term Partners those guys
get left out in the dust and the women
don't come back to them until you know
maybe their youth is gone or whatever it
may be and then you end up with these
marriages that don't end up working out
because the guy isn't getting her best
but he still held to a certain standard
he has to provide so there was a chart I
think it might have been Leonardo
DiCaprio but if it's not forgive me Leo
for besmirching your honorable name but
it was like this guy dates women and
marries women and divorces them at the
exact like almost the exact same ages
like you have today at 24 and then like
yeah he doesn't date any girl over 25 25
yeah like he dates and then and then
dumps him then dates he like dates him a
smart man
very smart smart he's because here's the
thing let's be honest about it right the
women want him for his status and his
value right right they want to be around
uh you know an A-list celebrity whatever
so he's like okay you want to share my
time with a high status man I want the
the best and the brightest the problem
is this when men put women on uh we want
preferences this is what we wanted women
it's considered misogynistic and rude or
what or discrimination but when a woman
has standards it's considered
preferences it's completely okay for
women to exert their boundaries and what
they want in men but it's now okay for
men to do it men are shamed for doing it
think about what we're talking about in
this segment a guy could lose his job
and make less money and now he's not
economically attractive anymore and then
you get a divorce
but a man like even criticizing the fact
these women are overweight they've let
themselves go and it's considered
misogynistic or or sexist or I'll take
it a step further Society actually
encourages women to leave their men we
no longer provides because they get the
money 80 of divorces are initiated by
women the family courts destroy men
they're they're heavily gynocentric
gynocentric so what is is there any
benefit to really getting married in
today's day and age I can't see many
even social media you see all the time
girls leaving their man for other men
and it's funny because when you're
married to a woman right guess what
happens let's say you lose your job like
you said earlier and you're no long you
know I would say you're no longer like
attractive to her she can go cheat and
have fun on the side and then still
let's start from the beginning right so
uh you you said you encourage men not to
get married is that opinion both of you
guys have yeah we we there's a few
situations where you you should make
better off being single yeah honestly
all right so you want to just give us
the bullet points I know I know we've
talked about it quite a bit but let's go
through it now just to start from the
beginning why shouldn't get married
um well the the a big reason why is
because like
um marriage is a traditional thing and a
lot of women aren't traditional you know
uh you know let's let's be honest I'm
just gonna have to say things that might
offend people women are more promiscuous
than they've ever been yep you're going
to have to train a lot of bad habits out
of your girlfriend and or wife to make
her a suitable candidate to be your
long-term partner to raise children
because the problem is this Society
nowadays you got this rap music you got
city girls teaching girls all this other
stuff these are bad habits not conducive
to a good long-term girlfriend and or
wife of your child you know what I'm
saying last thing you want is your son
to be walking down the playground but
hey dude I saw your mom's like but on
only fans like that's terrible you know
what I'm saying like and a lot of Rhodes
is dealing with the consequences of that
right now for poor decisions in the past
but that's what I'm saying so like women
are more promiscuous now they don't they
don't want uh they don't want to follow
male leadership you know uh they don't
want to um they don't want to adhere to
traditional traits but they expect you
to adhere to all your masculine
traditional traits so it's a bad trade
for you A lot of the time and only not
only that why would you sign a contract
with someone that's incentivized to
break it yeah and you you they break
that contract they get half your stuff
exactly not only that most women marry
up so by default more than likely
whatever woman you deal with is going to
make less money than you so and not only
that but when she when she's married
that's when the sexless marriages start
that's when the this bit you know the
the disrespect begins or whatever so
it's not in a man's best interest to get
married in today's State because a lot
of women are not fit wives to be honest
Tim I was actually married before right
so I'm speaking from my personal opinion
as well as being married but I'll say
this regarding marriage there was no
there was no benefit for me being in
that marriage versus not being in that
marriage so when I was single dating the
same girl I had the same benefits but
now being married I'm above the state
into my intimate life so if I want to
leave as ask permission to leave and
guess what they're going to take a
portion if I want to do certain things
so I'm just saying like regarding
marriage itself what's the benefit for
men honestly not much other than having
kids and even then it's kind of like
okay you could have kids books what you
you know what up marriage my thing is
look I'd rather go to Colombia find a
nice a nice chick over there Marry Her
come out to the US real talk here's
another thing too I'm gonna say it as
well yeah more than likely if you marry
a woman in today's day and age she's
gonna have a past okay women always want
women want a man with a future but a man
does not want a woman that has a past
but the problem is that if I say I don't
want to pass that's considered
misogynistic toxic whatever but no I'm
taking a huge Risk by marrying you and
having children with you so I need to
make sure just like you want me to be
able to provide for the family that
you're going to be a dutiful wife and
not embarrass me and the family because
when women cheat their serious negative
consequences to it that can destroy a
family get pregnant by another man
whatever it is it just it just doesn't
work so
a lot you know if you're gonna get
married you're going to want a woman
that has a lower Notch count men are
literally designed to want a woman that
has a lower Notch count are you going to
find that in the west very tough man I
just after that point as well so when I
married this District Corrections a
single mom uh just when I first came to
America and you know at the beginning it
was cool Rosie everything was cool but
then it started getting into like
demanding okay you know what spend more
time with my kid and I need to you know
to do to do these things whatever and I
was like you know what this wasn't part
of our agreement at the beginning like
you know it was us helping each other
out whatever the point here is that like
they can now accept more boundaries on
you and demands on you and because
you're not situation it's kind of like
okay this is my wife I should do this
because if I don't she might lead me and
her her leaving me is very very powerful
because now I'm gonna lose half my stuff
that being said I left her because I
knew going forward if I stayed any
longer I could be hell liable for a lot
of things like maybe child support maybe
even you know having to pay alimony so I
got out as fast as possible under that
year but I'm saying most guys they stick
hey you know what I'll stick with her
you know do bullcrap whatever and then
they get finessed because they pay you
know all that stuff they got to pay so
cheaper to keeper that's not terrible
and one last thing I want to say because
I know that the feminists might get mad
at me whatever for me saying that yeah
man yeah they already sent me death
threats every day so it is what it is so
I'll just go all the way um the thing is
this um female promiscuity does have
consequences it's just that we don't
tell women this because we don't want to
tell them the truth right when you lie
women by you know go ahead girl do your
thing
all I'm saying is that
if you're gonna marry a woman her past
does matter for you as a guy and there's
studies that show this that the more
Partners a woman has the lower her
ability to probably have to pair bond
with you and or have a marriage that's
going to last it has significant uh
consequences if the woman was had a
promiscuous pass so guys need to be
smart and know that if you're going to
pick a woman for a long-term
relationship to have children with you
got to know what you're doing and in
today's Western culture women are
incentivized to be promiscuous so it's
like and I shouldn't be admitting this
as a guy that that you know dates
casually whatever but for the women out
there that might be watching her guys
that are thinking about getting married
this stuff matters guys you need to look
at this check out the story we got go
ahead wife's response to husband's
message to lose weight goes viral she
should have given you divorce papers
here's the story a guy bought uh he
posted online saying he purposefully
bought his wife a dress that was too
small for he wanted her to lose weight
the response how sick and disgusting she
should divorce you she can gorge herself
eat whatever she wants she owes you
nothing and she gets half your stuff
um there you go what what incentive is
there you know what I'll say this too to
all of the all of the the women who may
get angry about hearing the stuff
if you don't like hearing this I'm not
saying this to say any of it's good or
right or anything like that but now
you're hearing what men are thinking and
what men are talking about and what men
want yeah what they'll never say and
there was a Peloton commercial too that
got people offended because the guy last
Last Christmas I think it was yeah the
the guy uh bought her a treadmill you
bought her a yeah Peloton which is like
a bike yeah a bike and uh and there was
a bunch of Rage like are you telling
your wife that she needs to lose weight
blah blah blah and this just shows the
crazy clown world that we're in where
having standards on women is considered
misogynistic or awful you know what I'm
saying and it's all you're simply
telling her is Hey listen if you want to
continue to get this security and
provisioning and relationship with me
you need to also perform there's a
burner performance on men but there's
never a burner performance on women
women are we have a bunch of social
conventions out there that allow women
to misbehave act poorly be obese be
crass be annoying and with zero
consequence if a woman is fat love your
curves girl hey wait wait if a woman is
rude it's okay they just can't handle
you you know if she's strong and
independent you know what he has small D
energy he's not worthy of your time you
know you go girl but if a guy's a loser
hey man you're a loser you live with
your mom in your basement you're a dork
whatever men are there's negative
reinforcement to mistakes made if you're
a man but there are not neg there's not
negative reinforcement for bad female
decisions and the thing is this who
loses the women who lose because they
end up single because men select who
gets married okay you want to hear my
favorite conspiracy theory yeah let's do
it all right you know the dove real BD
campaign
so they got bigger women plus size women
fat women for their kids Victoria's
Secret's doing that too yeah yeah yeah
but here's the thing about the the the
the the dove real Beauty campaign right
so they got like bigger women plus size
women yeah all right you know you know
Ben and Jerry's obviously ice cream ice
cream yeah guess what come there's one
company that owns both Unilever so the
the joke conspiracy theory is that the
the they sell the ice cream to all these
women get them really overweight and
then do commercials saying you're so
beautiful you keep buying like because
you do these ad campaigns for soap we
got all these super attractive models
and these women who keep eating your ice
cream you know they're going to be out
of shape and feel bad so you got to make
the commercial sound hey it's great it's
great but but look at this you get the
body positivity movement yeah you get
all these ads with morbid Leo based
women that are like at serious risk of
of Health complications it's horrifying
there's there's nothing like that for
men no there's there's no man body
positivity movement I mean maybe like no
male plus size models I don't see oh
where's the Men's Fitness magazine with
a big fat morbidly obese Guy saying like
this this actually reminds me of the
circle squared hoax guys you guys know
about um James Lindsey peterborgian
Helen pluck Rose they they spoofed a
bunch of journals one of them was fat
bodybuilding okay I don't know if this
got accepted but the idea was why is
muscle the preferred you know
bodybuilding fat bodybuilding is you
should be able able to eat a bunch of
food get really really fat and that's
bodybuilding too
but but it doesn't exist no there's no
there's no like my there's no big ad
campaign where it's like a big fat dad
bod guy you know just sitting there like
I eat a lot of Twinkies yeah they don't
do that and when you and it's amazing
because like I use the example before
the analogy like if I walked around on a
dressing heels and I said oh well you
know I'm really good at doing this you
should accept me for whatever it sounded
asinine right but that's how women sound
when they say I make a lot of money and
I'm a I'm a corporate exec whatever men
don't care about that these are
considered masculine traits no matter
how much feminists want to argue with us
about it like earning money becoming
high-powered High status whatever these
are things that men tend to do and women
find attractive and Men they're
masculine traits so if you have them
cool Plus for you but it's irrelevant
towards your sexual market value and yes
like I said there's never going to be a
body positivity for men because I always
say for a man to be attractive to women
he's got to live in a fact-based reality
he cannot men don't get the privilege of
living in a Disney fairy tale I can't
tell you how many women I know it's okay
you'll find a good girl don't worry
she'll come your way blah blah blah no
that's cap because that's like me
telling a lion Hey listen lion if you
just wait and you'll find that gazelle
man don't worry about it right to you
he'll come right to you you just need
more time no you need to tell that line
what you need to be stalking your prey
you need to be out at night hiding in
the grass you might need two of your
buddies to help you whatever it is and
then when they're not looking you gotta
jump on them that's what it takes to get
women you got to reveal unflattering
realities about how women really May
select to get them but women get the
privilege of saying I'm gonna wait
around and the right guy will come
because they can they get the privilege
of being able to believe in Disney fairy
tales because they're the gazelle you
can't do that as a man you're the lion
if you don't know what you're doing
you're gonna die you want to get girls
you have to know these unflaughting
realities with men and I think that's
why this type of content is exploding in
popularity we're not just men but also
women because men are learning what it
takes to actually be attractive to women
you know not being a pushover not being
soft you know having these bad boy
Tendencies You Know and then women are
learning okay Men actually are different
they want me to be attractive and
feminine and submissive but other tired
of being lied to yeah there you go and
you know and but real quick I think
that's one of the reasons why feminists
get so mad at this stuff there's a uh I
knew this uh a friend of mine his dad
was a physicist we are talking about M
Theory quantum physics you know the the
top tier the unified theory and I was
like is this is this real is this it is
the universe this 12 dimensional
membrane or whatever this crazy theory
is and he said there's a lot of problems
with we can't figure out but you got a
lot of scientists who have dedicated 60
years of their lives to this scientific
theory and they will never give that up
so you prove them wrong and they're like
my whole life was wasted and broken so
now you have these women they're 35 they
have good careers they make six figures
and if you say men have a tendency to
not want not want to date that they're
gonna get mad yeah they have to get they
have to shame you you have to be wrong
you are wrong it's not true I did
everything right I know you did I know
you did what they told you to do but and
I'm not saying it's right I'm just
saying you you look at the studies the
Tendencies exist so it's going to be a
lot harder for you like going to college
not a good idea and all these kids were
like but I was told to go to college I
did exactly what I was told great now
you're massively in debt you can't get a
job
a lot of a lot of uh women that we bring
on our show that get mad when we say
these types of things they say well
that's not fair and I tell them life
isn't fair it's not fair that you get to
go into a nightclub without paying it's
not fair that there are men that are
willing to pay your rent for not doing
anything we had a girl on on our show
yesterday she's on unemployment she's
riding around in rolls royces and
McLarens and she she went to Vegas today
yep an unemployed man would never be
able to do that why but she's young and
attractive and she's a woman so there's
privileges on both sides and
unfortunately ladies some of the things
that men can do you can't ah dude like
growing up how many how many women how
many guys did you know that became
homeless how many women did you know
that became homeless exactly I mean I'm
not saying it's it's absolute there's
obviously homeless women but but I think
yeah uh one in five uh homeless people
are women yeah some like it's really
really low because women can just find a
guy and live with them yeah not it's not
it's not absolute it's not of course you
know but
suicides overwhelmingly dudes exactly
I'm curious victims of violent crime men
because I had a woman one time say I was
like give me a privilege that women have
that men don't or right and she was like
well you could walk around at night and
not feel scared and I was like feeling
versus reality are two different thing
things men are actually far more prone
to be victims of violent crime which is
what you're trying to say yeah we gotta
go to the Super church we went a little
longer we got to do this bonus segment
later where we can get even more
offensive sure yes all right let's see
Chad Randall says I'm sorry if you
haven't already give that like button a
little tap subscribe to timcast.com
because if you think this was offensive
wait till we go to the members only
segments oh man let's get it I guess
we're in there right yeah
all right Chad Randall says I want an
update on Tim's app when will it be done
oh man we are working as fast as humanly
possible I literally work in this
company and I was like can I give you
more money to make it faster and they're
like yes and I said can I give you even
more money to make it go faster and they
said that's the limit there's just
there's just only so much you can do so
the new website looks amazing we're
going to do an app you're going to be
able to listen to podcast episodes with
the screen off all that good stuff
that's the plan man
but takes time to build stuff so we're
working on it
hey East F says I got a notification
today yay hey that's cool
Oppo says we have Tim pool the legendary
fence sitter versus fresh and fit the
legendary fence Busters will Myron
sacrifice the rest of his hair to defeat
the beanie will fresh unleash the
stutter barrage
find out next time on DBZ
that's awesome buddy it wasn't a
question excellent
uh let's see okay I don't know what this
means Rainer Chen says here's to fresh
and fit if Tim pool joined your podcast
what could it take for you to Frank
Castle him oh Tim is fam man yeah
Frank Castle because uh because
um look at his shirt yeah we're The
Punisher basically I went viral on Tick
Tock uh like back in like late 2020 for
saying like if a girl reschedules on a
date you need to punish that bad
behavior maker by the first round of
drinks and went viral because like put
it heavy or we eat dogs it's like no you
just need to let her know that you have
boundaries and she can't disrespect your
time and then they're like are you
punish bad behavior I was like you know
what I'm Frank Castle now so I just took
the name The Punisher and every show to
do right there's for whatever reason
this random ratchet chick that goes
crazy right yeah and we'll give her a
chance you know what please calm down
we're on our talk show right now you
can't be too loud and they get going on
and on he said you know what that's it
had enough get out of here yeah and I
just kicked around I think it's called
Frank castling I mean the chat's
hilarious because they'll start putting
Castle uh emojis in there when they grow
up or Frank Castle Lodi I'm like all
right get the F out you know and then
they leave the team is cool man it's
cool yeah Tim and Tim is mad cool all
right I'll take it I'll take it I got
these these these guys from this fancy
pockets in Miami some a cool dude that
must make it true yeah that's right all
right let's see
Conti 123 says we had a lady tried to
run a military gate and the MP had to
smash her window to get her out because
she refuses now she's trying to make the
MP look bad by lying sad world we live
in damn that's tough man yeah dude
all right let's see people are saying ah
fresh and fit based next show Rolo
tomasi LOL free John Doyle on Twitter
his future POTUS shout out to heck off
Kami Network do you guys know uh Rolo is
that I say yeah he's our boy he's a
friend of ours he's actually the author
of the rational meal a very cool guy
good dude have him on a show man he
follows me yeah yeah where's a good dude
we'll uh we'll check it out yeah I'll
fight you naked said just saw Leah's
interview with voice it was very
interesting seeing a girl who aspires to
be a stay-home mom when I'm old enough
to be her dad the wokies would have got
away with it if it weren't for all you
meddling kids I just feel like women
have really been lied to and if more
than anything it makes me sad to watch
him try to play a second-rate version of
the men's game yeah breaks my heart
Lydia I'm so curious how many of your
friends actually have a boyfriend or are
married right now uh most of my friends
are married and having children right
now awesome good that's excellent that's
awesome
I'm a little jealous but it's all good
we'll get there all right BlackRock
vegan says I just moved from PA to FL
it's nice here Tim lots of Freedom lots
of rural land for cheap and
unincorporated areas Luke was right join
us Tim
dude I lived in in Florida January and
February was like when we could go
outside but maybe I'll get a big a big
you know pole barn or something and air
conditioning hold on Tim you spent a
week with us I guarantee you'll love
Miami I'm telling you bro you might want
to make it back here alive
apartment or they buy a home in Florida
I I love Miami it was fantastic it's
just the weather dude
I go outside every day I skate and it
was like really brutal we'd go outside
in the backyard 100 degrees maximum
humidity and I just like fall over and
we'll just melt you know how many air
conditioned skate parks yeah
I went to one skate park in Miami I
don't remember it had no AC though oh
and it was seriously probably like 110
degrees inside and I went inside and I
was like these people are nuts they had
a fan like trying to pull the album like
dude we're in Miami
just more humid air on me ac must have
been broken or something and they were
trying they had to keep the doors open
otherwise you'd go to business you know
I get it yeah
all right let's see
what do we got Jonathan Duggar says Ian
is right on this thing the Ice is like
heavy weight on one end of a seesaw one
side Falls and the other Rises shout out
to Ian interesting some science it
checks out
yeah yeah it's it's got a name um Nathan
Simpson says Ian is Right isostatic
rebound is a thing my home province in
Canada was covered in glaciers during
the Ice Age and as the crust rebounds
over time we sometimes experience small
earthquakes huh wow interesting I never
knew damn
yeah yeah they said Atlanta sunk Beneath
the Sea as well as being covered by mud
it went down interesting Florida's next
time all right Eamon says first Super
Chat listening for two years now hey
appreciate it man love the show hi to
Lydia speaking of getting hustled got
hustled in a nola on bachelor's trip
woke up with fake phone and 2300 spend
on debit card police didn't care to take
a report oh no oh yeah that's that's I'm
not surprised
that happens bro
Joe harsh Barger Tim what if they are
driving gas prices up because they want
to make it more convenient to drive
electric cars rather than gas ones I
don't know about all that uh I do know I
have an electric I have a Tesla it's
great but you can't really do much with
it outside of like running errands you
can drive it to the store if you drive
it back but taking it on longer trips
like we drove it three hours we had to
stop plug it in and then chill for like
20 minutes as it charges back up that's
annoying like I'm not too familiar with
Tesla's like you plug it into like an
outlet or something like that or if you
plug you can plug it into an outlet and
again it'll give you three travel miles
per hour of charge
yeah okay so if you get the actual the
actual charger like the superchargers
you can actually charge it up to about
80 in 20 minutes okay so that's not that
bad but this is one of those things
though that's a supercharger it's a
normal plug oh it just comes with yeah
yeah yeah okay all right so like when
you pull up to the we're not like uh
it's the outlet that it has okay it
comes with a wall charger you got to get
one installed they're like 500 bucks to
install in your home okay but if you're
driving you know we would drive from
here to like Philly we stop at a rest
station you plug in the supercharger and
then you go inside grab some food come
back out your car's fully charged you're
good to go not as convenient as palm to
a gas station you pump up in a minute
you're done you're good to go so we got
the Range Rover diesel so we'll be back
yeah we use diesel that's that's a
little glitch yeah diesels Diesel's
great Ranger saves we actually got a ram
because we're trying to do uh mobile
shows so we got we got we got a trailer
we need to set it up there's a lot of
work got to be done to it and just
there's too many plates spinning to like
get everything going but we're probably
we want to go to Nashville and Austin
and Nashville and back and make it a
trip where we like hang out for a while
she was underrated City man yeah a lot a
lot of fun it's a fun place to be yeah
Hector Garcia says sending love from
homestead Tim and don't sleep on it they
recently started a bunch of development
I'm talking Tesla charging and
entertainment complexes prices going up
and people gentrifying West to the
Redlands West to the Redlands wow
telling you man South Florida is going
to be booming in a couple years I'll
tell you some of the best food best food
yeah when you would get like legit food
from like an Abuelita and she's like
cooking
Grandma's cooking yeah really good we
would go in and it would be like this
little hole in the wall place and you
know that it was like they got the meat
they cooked it there's not there's no
crap in it it's like family cooking that
was the coolest thing killed the
chickens in the back or whatever you
know no no no no definitely definitely
yeah they'd I once lived across the
street from a chicken slaughterhouse you
hear them all screaming at night oh man
you ever had Jamaican food uh Peter has
entered the chat yeah but like New York
Jamaican food I'm taking you all bro
we're coming up Miami I got you you and
Lydia yeah let's do it yeah I mean we
could we get this trailer set up we
could come down to to Miami there you go
let's go we could do our show for a week
then we you know what the plan was
we would spend Monday Monday through
Thursday doing the shows just in the
trailer and then Friday night we would
get a venue and do a live showing it's
not super easy because we got to get
camera set up we got live we got the
internet set up so you got our studio
yeah but the idea would like sell
tickets have people come and actually
get to hang out sit in the audience and
then Super chats plus like audience
questions so people would love that bro
I've thought about that like you know if
you have an audience you could
definitely do that Friday nights well
because Friday nights people want to go
out yep they don't want to sit at home
and listen to a podcast on the internet
so they're out doing something we find
this venue where they can drink and hang
out and then we're getting the best of
both words everyone's having a good time
they can come here exactly that's smart
yeah before
um 10 p.m in Miami yeah okay yeah best
auntie ever says hey Tim just looking
for a recommendation for an AR for home
defense thanks
um I'll just throw shout out to the sigm
400 I mean you know I I've recently just
got a bunch of guns Steven Crowder sent
me the Sega 400 told me it was like the
Cadillac of AR-15s or whatever and it
took me like a year to get it because it
was just like just some it was just
difficult I lived in New Jersey New
Jersey crazy laws we moved to West
Virginia now it's easy yeah that thing
is amazing it really is super easy super
uh uh just
easy is the best way to put it so for me
and I'm like I don't have a lot of
experience I only got you know a year or
so now actually working with guns and
training okay I went out and we went I
had the instructor and everybody showed
me how to use it and it was it was
fantastic yeah Glocks and errors are
just you know yeah
I wonder how wait bro oh wait I didn't
say it on air never mind but like the
the the muzzle break on it yeah you know
it was it's powerful like The Recoil was
very light this is a 556. home defense
though I guess in AR I just got a nine
millimeter AR rifle I like that um
because you can use hollow points or
frangible nine millimeters so there's
less penetration so it's safer and just
you know more home defense though yeah
but wouldn't you want to like you know
kind of end them
yeah I mean a whole point our series
okay I thought you meant fringes and
like okay yeah yeah well so you know
like hollow points that's not gonna go
through the walls oh okay all right yeah
because it hits them it goes it stays in
them and they splatters exactly and
expands and mushroom tips yeah I mean to
be honest I talked about this before I
was like I don't want to end them you
know I don't even have to shoot somebody
but you got that's the hard realities I
told you the story about when I'm in in
Miami they said his house invaded and he
walked down the stairs no idea what's
happening chest yeah so sometimes a sad
reality is like you don't get to make
that choice they made it for you right
they said in the uncut version
all right let's see Justin Bell says not
having children is equivalent to ending
your genetic line that has been evolving
for how long billions of years we gain
sentience to end ourselves we'll we'll
get into bit of this in the in the bonus
segment too because that's that's the
stuff where YouTube gets really mad and
we're gonna you know
all right let's see what we got ASU says
fresh and fit did the red pill
manosphere go mainstream Tim can you
have Rolo and Coach Greg Adams on the
show on the podcast I'm not familiar
I've heard of Rollo for sure I don't
know who coach Greg is you guys know
he's a good dude he's a good dude Adams
yeah
um we we actually like uh I think we
talk about like men's issues and stuff
yeah relatively often it's mostly
political and cultural not as often as
we used to yeah not as often as we used
to we actually like one of our first
guests was was he like a psychology yeah
uh Sean's yeah yeah yeah oh yeah okay
yeah but it's but it's mostly because
it's like a a gender is obviously a huge
driver in cultural politics yeah and and
how movies are being made and how this
stuff is doing you know is is is
changing and happening so and also it's
trending very well too these topics are
very hot yeah um yeah a lot of guys are
struggling man and I think uh since you
know my my prediction is as women become
more and more selective and they deal
with a smaller smaller portion of men
you know that top 10 percent of men and
it dwindles down more and more guys are
going to go looking for answers they're
going to go on Google how do I get girls
they're going to find us you know what
I'm saying and try to figure the figure
this out we say so many marriages and
like relationships is crazy man yeah Joe
Nova sales has any app as a dating app
if you're creepy enough
did you hear about the guys who are
hitting up woman on LinkedIn yo there's
a hole Yeah you can do it's a whole
technique
which is cringy to me I got a I got a
buddy that does it he uses LinkedIn
again
dude it could work because you got you
got status on there if you do it right
you're coming from like kind of like a
mentor like higher status like so the
girls women are there's a reason why
like secretaries
you could do that too but like it's just
I guess it's
I say use every Avenue man I'm not use
every Avenue guys full approach online
dating LinkedIn games hit me up to go on
a date who's the VP
it's like I don't know it's yeah but
it's cringy yeah all right I say use
everything no shame okay the Civic
nationalist says I ride around the UK on
my 500 CC motorbike and I used to pick
up chicks in nightclubs never once used
a dating app but I did meet my GF of one
year on Instagram and when she's not at
Uni we go on the same rides God Save the
Queen
oh okay
Jay Rich says are we headed towards a
world where the average man and woman
won't settle for each other and
ultimately live alone and pay to play
with the top one percent of either
gender questions when they need to would
that be better or worse than what we
have now the only thing I would say is
it's not going to be the average man to
be willing to sell it's going to be the
average woman won't settle exactly it's
going to be because average women now if
you ask them what they want in a man
they they're not describing an average
man they're describing a man that's
extra above average it was one winner
from the show talking to hundreds of
women yeah they will never submit they
don't give a [ __ ] oh I'd rather have a
dog cat live alone go ahead yeah yeah
they don't they really don't want uh so
they don't want an average man at all
man because we like to ask the girls hey
well how tall does he got to be how much
money he's got to earn before to average
it out from all the hundreds of women we
spoke it to over six feet tall at least
a hundred thousand dollars a year uh
attractive in somewhat shape not being
fat you're already describing a man
that's in the top you know five percent
you know yeah oh man because only ten
percent of all U.S households make over
a hundred thousand dollars a year so if
you extrapolate that for single men that
are attracted that meet these other
requirements of yours that are six feet
we're talking top five top three times
four percent point one because because
they're single as well so you got it you
gotta yeah you gotta factor out I'm
being generous think about this too
single as well right there so these guys
who are highly sought after they're
probably already dating somebody exactly
yes multiple people and that's here's
another equalizer clout if you have
clout nowadays it's kind of like the
social currency you have that you have
access to a lot of women yeah and it's
just the thing is is I think um well
it's not even I think at this point
after interviewing hundreds of women I
know I know they have an abundance
mentality that is almost detrimental to
their ability to lock down a guy because
they think well I went to this social
situation where I went to this party I
was on this yacht and I met all these
kinds of guys these these guys are
abundant no they're not like their
abundant may be from from a they want to
sleep with you uh uh because women don't
understand that just like women have
like a dual mating strategy men do too
you know you have the girls that you
want to just like hook up with then you
got girls that are wifey material the
problem is that a lot of women conflate
a guy wanting to sleep with them and
give them attention as okay well this
guy is a potential candidate for a
relationship too and what they don't
understand is that you know relationship
value and you know attractive value are
two different things you know and a lot
of guys and and here's the other thing
too I always tell women to this thing
and they get mad at me but you know
feminists we want to get mad at this
what it is
a man's value is derived from how many
attractive women can you get and sleep
with a woman's values determined by what
caliber of man can you attract and most
importantly retain if you don't got a
ring you lost the thing is this we like
to give our participation trophies and
don't like to have losers especially
when we deal women women who like to
coddle them no if you are not married or
in a serious relationship with a man
that you love admire and respect and
want to be with you lost as a woman and
as a man if you can't attract an
abundant amount of women or at least a
woman that you find attractive that you
want then you lost as a man the problem
is that we don't like to have winners
and losers we want to give everyone a
participation Trophy and it's okay to
call a man a loser but not okay to call
a woman loser and the thing is this they
want to use they want to play the game
on easy mode because let's be honest
dating four minutes on easy mode but
they want to get hard mode benefits
that's right they want to be able to say
well I have guys in my DMs hey well I
got I get invited to these kinds of
parties white guys taking me out on
dates blah blah blah I should be able to
be uh promiscuous as well no you got the
game on easy mode so you don't get hard
mode benefits if you want the Exotic
drops from the boss you know you don't
get that on easy mode yeah you gotta
yeah you gotta exactly so like men play
the game on hard mode so therefore we
can go ahead and you know uh you know be
promiscuous we can go ahead and you know
have a bunch of women because it's very
difficult for men to get women and and
the thing is women get mad at me when I
say this too
men don't cheat there's exercise options
when they get to a certain level and
here's another thing too like another
fallacy that they have well I deserve a
high value man cool you know what if you
have a high value man that's fine but
guess what you're gonna have to share
him in the bedroom what that's BS why
can't he just be faithful why can't this
man just be faithful to me and I have to
tell him all the time okay
there's two families you're in one
family on one family right
you I I inherit my million dollars you
were born poor and you had to earn your
million dollars you had to scale up
three businesses whatever
20 30 years passes by I spent all my
money maybe betting on Dogecoin whatever
no offense to the Dogecoin investors
right and then you you built up three
different businesses up to two million
dollars net worth and then I come to you
and tell you Hey listen you need to
invest your money like this you're gonna
look at me like are you crazy I'm not
listening to you why well because I
inherited my million whereas I inherit
my million for my family whereas you had
to earn your million so how can you
dictate to a self-made millionaire how
to invest his money when he made it
himself and you inherited your money and
that's what I tell women you inherited
your value you cannot dictate how a man
Spends His value when he had to earn it
you must preserve your value men must
create their value we play by different
rules women do earn their value though
they gotta they got in in terms of
depending on the guy they're going for
looking good staying fit taking care of
themselves but they're moral value
yeah it's inherent to them so yeah I get
it yeah and by no means am I saying a
woman's existence is easy makeup wearing
heels and all sort of stuff it ain't
easy but what I am saying is that
they're given the value up front and
it's their job to preserve it but check
this out it's also technology I think is
is one of the big problems
technology is one of the reasons women
have to go get jobs in the first place
because the high value men can now get
with whatever they whoever they want
average women don't have a guy who's
going to support them they have to get a
job
I would say I would blame it more on the
lack of the father in a household the
reason why you know the divorce rates
are so high and you know women are not
happy with men is because the father
used to be a critical component in mate
selection and the father would pick a
man that was conducive to his daughter's
long-term success from a security
standpoint you know he didn't have to be
the most arousing guy to be the nerd
whatever but that guy was going to be a
really good husband and a really good
father the thing is though since women
make their own money right off of alpha
seed beta need right shout out to Rolla
tomasi if they make their own money they
no longer want that security from that
guy that might be you know a loser they
want the hot guy that that that is
attractive and makes money more money
than them so it's when you're and
there's a bunch of other reasons you
know why Society fails when you leave
remove the father but the father is a
critical component and his wife being
able to lock down a man and be happy in
a relationship as well all right we got
this one from simulation 115 he says
what are the guests thoughts on otaku
and Anime culture and its effect on
dating
honestly man I love anime however I
would say though uh it's created it's
created a space where like there's a
bunch of guys that only how to put the
standout bubble and it's kind of like
they
I don't sound harsh but they only look
at women
citizen in a nice way they look at women
I just don't swear bro yeah they look at
women as like um characters and when
look at the miscarriages kind of like
they
um
I don't know I don't know how to put
this in the worst bro they treat them
like they're not real they treat exactly
like some kind of negot sex dolls so to
me it's like okay you watch anime bro
but that's not real life it's kind of
like a perception of how which things
could be but it's not real life so go
out there talk to girls live a good
lifestyle but remember that anime is for
fun when you're bored but it's not real
life that's all I say here here's a good
one Hayden says I make over 100k a year
live in a more rural State 30 and have
no kids most girls my age have kids kids
get hurt in breakups too I want my
relationship to be number one not
another man's kid marriage remains after
the kids leave the house
being there for each other is part of
number one a lot of guys don't want to
marry someone who's already got kids too
I know and that's just I I agree 100 you
should not marry a single mom right this
is going to get controversial yeah no
you're married stupid stupid and like uh
no for a young guy coming up especially
when you're on your rise and you have no
kids yourself tomorrow a single mother
with a kid you literally just saying
Santa or something you know what I'm
gonna put my dreams behind focus on this
person's seed and raise them I'm not
saying it's a bad I think I'm just
saying why would you do that when it's
not your kid so my thing is look if
you're young you want to make you know
you know something of yourself and be
successful
you don't want to have you don't want to
have ROBLOX you're like that can
actually damage your your progress so
I'm just saying look
don't date single mothers because one
you'll take care of someone else's kid
two it may pull you back from your
dreams and three think about this
there's millions of other girls that are
single with no kids why are you going to
that girl she's already had somebody
that gave her imprint and you're not
gonna break that imprint from from uh
from biological and from like a
financial standpoint it's just not
intelligent to do that like you're
you're basically what's happening is you
have a hundred percent responsibility
with like no Authority because this is
not your child so you know the
disciplining there's going to be some
you know arguments probably with the
with the wife on that
um that's not your kids so they're
probably not going to respect you the
same they're gonna you're not my daddy
you know and then you're putting all
this money and effort into a child that
isn't yours and the woman can leave at
any time you're gonna it's gonna hurt
you twice as bad because you're gonna
build an attachment to that child to
some degree and you have zero rights to
that child if something goes down so
it's in a man's best interest to have
his own kids and to marry a woman that
doesn't have kids and raise your own
seat because at least because family
Court's already bad enough yeah you're
already going to lose your own
biological kids more than likely yeah so
you better at least have it be where you
have a small chance of being able to see
them versus having a stepchildren that
aren't even yours and last thing in your
own home discipline is made up to the
woman because remember that's not your
kid so if you're hitting them if you
punish them remember his mother really
instincts to say hey you know what
that's not your kid don't don't punish
them yeah it's a Bad Bet for men yeah
Caleb bhakta says women might age like
milk but you Mig Towers Never Grow Up oh
I mean I wouldn't identify ourselves as
as uh make Towers but hey no comment but
I mean yeah I mean like here's the thing
like like we don't have a problem with
guys in that Community they they have
they they point out facts a lot they
speak a lot of truths man and they
choose so basically they've looked at
the sexual Marketplace that we just
described with the globalized
marketplace and my program steroids
whatever and they've decided I'm leaving
I'm not playing and that's fine that's
fine we ain't gonna shame those guys
because honestly is it worth it yo is it
think about it is it really worth dating
no it is what are you gaining from this
you get married you might lose you might
lose you mean a girl it's just like
there's a lot of risk look at the facts
oh look at the um the whole agenda here
is it worth it probably not yeah keep it
a buck I'm not gonna knock the mgtow
guys I'll just say this for us we enjoy
going out there dating casually doing
our thing you know womanizing you know
we enjoy it if guys want to learn how to
do it we're here if you don't want to be
in the marketplace cool we're gonna
knock you for it but we understand where
they're coming from yep wolfstar says H
pound H pound I think he meant h3h3
proved Tim is a fool Ethan is a Chad and
Tim can't get a girlfriend because he's
a pathetic loser did did h3h really talk
about me
I don't know if uh they actually talk
about me I mean I would be I would I
would be yeah absolutely I mean h3h is a
huge show it's talking about little old
me wow people on the internet on that
radar you're blooming they'll talk about
you no matter what yeah I like when
you've got drama shows like h3h3 where
their whole thing is to like
drama not issues then it makes sense
they would want to talk about me because
I was criticizing them and they were
doing this thing with Crowder or
whatever but I mean
there's no real overlap between anything
that we do like you know all the
conversation with Sam Cedar about uh
deontology or utilitarianism and the
guy's not smart enough to know what
those things are and then Ethan will
bring that guy on his show who's not
smart enough to know basic philosophical
Concepts to be able to talk about things
like solipsism or whatever if we're
going to talk about like the current
political state of you know Taiwan China
which I'm not even an expert and then
some guy who does a drama show who's
like I don't do any research I just do
whatever I'm told by the government like
that's not even an overlap there by all
means guys like we're not we're not
we're not a pop culture podcast you know
what I mean so it's it's in his
potential best interest to be like aha
you know Tim pool or whatever and then
do this thing with Stephen Crowder
we we talk about a lot of stuff that's
extremely esoteric and it's not
particularly valuable which is tough
because I know that if we do a drama
show oh yeah if we do drama and gossip
and Britney Spears and all stuff and
Minecraft or fortnite that's money in
the bank yep we don't do that so it's
like it'd be so easy that's why it's
like it's it's like hey man if he if he
talks about me and he gets people to
know who I am it's I guess he's just
good in the in the long run free
marketing free marketing for you man
yeah yeah yeah hater's Gonna Hate yeah
but whatever I mean I thought I think I
think he's all right he's making he
makes a good content it's just drama
stuff it's pop culture we don't do that
all right let's see what else we got
Aaron says read Soren Kierkegaard father
of existentialism writing on self the
first stage where most people stick is
aesthetic which embodies the Arts and
the erotic they see boredom as the root
of all evil and is preoccupied with
making life interesting
yeah I mean that's like most people
though isn't it yeah I mean the worst
thing you could do to a woman is make
her bored you know that's that's the
biggest thing I I like when girls like
leave a guy or whatever when he's like
he just doesn't give her an emotional
roller coaster because women are slaves
to their emotions man there's a reason
why they love crime dramas why they want
you know they like certain types of
television and gossiping and all this
other stuff women are more interested in
people men tend to be more interested in
things right and unfortunately people
tend to come with drama which is why
women are more interested in it on a
balance of probabilities is this all
women know because I know there are some
feminism oh my God you're generalizing
generalizing is how the world works so
that people can prepare for how the
general World Works Sam Devlin says I
have always been believer that men and
women are created to be complementary to
one another yes my partner and I find
balance in each other and it is
beautiful side note my wonderful man
bought me a Peloton last year and I felt
like a queen hey there you go
yeah see that's how it should be yeah we
believe that men and women should be
together 100 however not get finessed
yeah you know just yeah we yeah men and
women are better together than they are
apart yes there's some situations that
make it almost impossible nowadays with
marriage and women being incentivized to
break that marriage contract but you
know it men and women work together
we've we've done it for centuries and
we've come pretty far right you're
talking looking at us in 1080P right now
right so right so here's a good one
Rondo says yo I never thought I'd see
fresh and fit on Tim cast fresh and fit
how do I convince my friend to not hate
women he had his heart broken when he
was dating
um yeah so he's going through that rage
range right yeah the biggest thing dude
is
you got to understand guys that you know
shout out to our boy Rolo again like I
agree with him 100 on this like women
love opportunistically man like you got
to bring something to the table and I
think a lot of the times when men get
frustrated with women it's because they
think that it's Disney fairy tale she's
gonna love me for me unconditional love
we we have discussion one time with
girls and you know they were all saying
like yeah I believe in unconditional
love again what do I always say women
get the privilege of living in a Disney
fairy tale you got to live in a
fact-based reality as a man women love
opportunistically they love you for what
you bring to the table and that's okay
you're not wrong with it don't hate them
for what they'll never beat you there
ain't gonna be no idealistic lover man
I'll say look man you gotta sound right
bro it's just your turn understand that
any woman you're with right now is for
season it may not be forever and that's
true for life nothing is forever so if
you were to go right now she breaks your
heart understandably definitely it sucks
but at the same time tomorrow Janet is
going to be there so there's more girls
out there it's just your turn don't take
it personal bro because it's not about
you it's about the whole agenda and
here's the other thing too that's why in
our our podcast we're so big on
self-improvement yeah because a lot of
guys need the Fulfillment through women
no guys you need the Fulfillment through
you you need to be working on your
business your Fitness becoming a better
man because when you become a better man
and a woman is just a compliment to your
life bang she's gonna immediately fall
into her place and her feminine she's
gonna know that you're on a path and
women
she's not your co-pilot guys she's your
flight attendant and the more you level
the more whatever they want to say the
options
she wants to follow your lead guys and
she's only going to follow your lead if
you got enough Pokemon badges a lot of
you guys got one Pokemon badge out here
heck trying to get chicks women want
leaders man so you guys got to become
and then you can come but you see how
she she broke his heart if he would
level up uh you know to a certain level
you could have her break your heart that
sucks of course but guess what you're at
a high level where you have options you
know to your life so if she messes up
guess what Janet's here Jackie's here so
it doesn't really matter it doesn't hurt
you that bad because you have options
for yourself so run on man well I think
we should uh we should get ready for
this members only segment so if you're
if you are not a member go to
timcast.com become a member the site's
taken off man I can't believe how many
people signed up it's huge we're hiring
people we're gonna have I think we're
gonna have like four uh five people in
The Newsroom within like a couple weeks
or so so that's huge nice yeah action no
I'm wrong it's like six
snap six people yeah so this is gonna be
huge go to tempgas.com become a member
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel hit that notification Bell you
can follow us on Instagram and Facebook
at Tim cast IRL and you can follow me at
timcast you guys want to shout out your
social media yeah uh we have a joint
page uh fresh and fit Miami we also have
YouTube as well fresh and fit and then
my personal one is Fresh Prince CEO and
then I'll unplug fit with two T's and
guys yeah get on us on our fresher fit
we do our our main podcast Monday
Wednesday Friday 6 p.m and then we do a
nighttime show every time we bring in
some lovely ladies and discuss dating
and reactive videos every night fresh
after hours and then we have a fresh and
fit Clips Channel check that out too an
Instagram course oh yeah the Amazon man
out now there you go you can also follow
me Ian crossland.net and at Ian crosson
on social media thanks all right I
wanted to close with a quote which I
don't usually do but I was thinking
about this quote while we were talking
tonight and uh this is something that's
been bothering me a lot about feminism
lately this quote is from Musashi and it
says truth is what you want it to be it
is what it is and you must Bend to its
power or live a lie and I think this is
exactly what's happening with feminism
and that is what breaks my heart wow
that was beautiful yeah hopefully that
that clears up in the next few years
anyway you guys can follow me on Twitter
at Sour Patch Lids as I attempt to get
more followers than Sour Patch Kids we
will see you all at timcast.com in the
bonus segment so thanks for hanging out
bye guys